le micro c'est parti et bien écoutez
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs avant de débuter mon propos
introductif je souhaite la bienvenue à
une délégation de députés marocains
conduite par la vice-présidente de la
Chambre des représentants du Royaume du
Maroc madame Nadia tout ami
dans le cadre du volley Jean du jumelage
institutionnel avec l'Assemblée
nationale alors on peut pas passer sous
silence l'actualité évidemment donc
permettez-moi également de saluer la
performance de votre équipe masculine de
football à la Coupe du Monde du Qatar
les Lions de les lions pardon les Lions
de l'Atlas viennent de marquer
l'histoire en se qualifiant pour les
quarts de finale je leur souhaite bonne
chance pour contre le Portugal et espère
que nos bleus pourront les retrouver en
demi-finale bien entendu voilà donc
j'imagine que les le bruit le soir
l'agitation dans Paris
vous vous en êtes responsable
de la délégation qui sont présents
également avec nous ce matin
un travail à important on l'a vu a déjà
été menée par le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
qui a été publiée en décembre 2020 et
nous l'ont présenté il y a 3 semaines un
rapport qui s'intitulaire prendre en
compte le sexe et le genre pour mieux
soigner un enjeu de santé publique sur
la base de cette audition qui a mis en
lumière la diversité des sujets couverts
par ce rapport et certaines pistes à
approfondir ne rapporteurs ont décidé de
centrer leurs travaux essentiellement
sur la santé des femmes au travail cela
nous permettra d'aborder de nombreux
sujets conditions de travail exposition
aux risques professionnels pénibilité
aménagement du temps de travail et des
temps de vie articulations entre vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle
charges mentale double journée burn out
un pack du télétravail aussi sur les
carrières par exemple grossesse des
femmes salariées et j'en passe nous
entamons nos travaux sur cette
thématique par une approche historique
et sociologique je suis très heureuse
d'accueillir soit en présentiel avec
nous ce matin soit par écran interposé
je vous vois mesdames bonjour donc
Muriel salles historienne spécialiste de
l'histoire des femmes dans les travaux
de recherche ont notamment porté sur les
questions de genre dans le domaine de la
santé et auteur en 2017 avec Catherine
Vidal d'un ouvrage intitulé femme et
santé encore une affaire d'homme le
titre vous l'aurez compris est très
évocateur elle interviendra à distance
et devra nous quitter à 9h15 donc on
fera peut-être rapidement les questions
à l'issue de son intervention Caroline
de Pau qui est à mes côtés ce matin
docteur en sociologie directrice de
l'Union régionale des professionnels de
santé médecins libéraux des
Hauts-de-France chercheuse associée au
centre lillois d'études et de recherche
sociologique et économiques auteur d'un
ouvrage intitulé la santé des femmes
publiée en juin dernier et enfin ils
aboulaient docteur en sociologie à
l'Université de Nantes spécialiste des
ateliers à la grossesse en milieu
professionnel qui interviendra en
visioconférence donc bienvenue à vous
toutes mesdames vous nous dresserez un
paranorama des inégalités de genre dans
le domaine de la santé et plus
particulièrement des liens entre travail
et santé des femmes vous nous direz
comment ces inégalités peuvent
s'articuler avec des inégalités
professionnelles nous aborderons
notamment la question des risques
professionnels quelle différence
constatez-vous entre les sexes quelles
en sont les facteurs explicatifs et
comment mieux les prendre en compte
alors que les accidents du travail ont
baissé de 27% chez les hommes entre 2001
et 2019 ils ont augmenté de 42% chez les
femmes sur la même période selon une
étude de l'Agence nationale pour la
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
les politiques de prévention sont moins
développées dans les secteurs
majoritairement occupés par des femmes
or aujourd'hui le risque d'accident du
travail est le même pour le secteur des
services à la personne que dans le BTP
les femmes où on retrouve d'ailleurs le
BTP de nombreuses femmes désormais et
notre collègue Dominique Verrien qui
était dans un cabinet
qui suivait des chantiers ne pourraient
pas me contredire les femmes sont
également deux fois plus exposées au
risque de troubles musculo-squelettiques
les TMS que les hommes or on considère
plus facilement la pénibilité liée à la
manutention de charges lourdes par
exemple que celle liées au gestes
répétitifs enfin une étude de l'Inserm a
montré une augmentation de 26% du cancer
du sein en cas de travail de nuit les
cancers d'origine professionnelle sont
souvent sous évaluées chez les femmes
cependant sur ces différents constats le
H&R appelle depuis plusieurs années à
une évolution des critères de pénibilité
au travail et à une prise en compte des
risques psychosociaux avez-vous
approfondi ce sujet mesdames nous
souhaitons également étudier les liens
entre les conditions socio-économiques
et la santé des femmes à la fois
physique et mentale notamment une plus
grande exposition au risque de
dépression qui touchent deux fois plus
les femmes que les hommes nous
évoquerons aussi le rôle de la médecine
du travail en matière de prévention
enfin ils aboulaient nous présentera ses
travaux sur la grossesse des femmes
salariées en jeu du suivi médical et de
son articulation avec l'emploi du temps
professionnel conditions de travail
aménagement des postes de travail je
laisse sans plus tarder la parole à
Muriel sales qui intervient à distance
et si vous le permettez donc on fera
l'échange avec les rapporteurs et les
membres de la délégation à l'issue de
votre intervention madame donc bienvenue
à vous on vous voit
français épais dans lequel on trouve
beaucoup de choses tout à fait
intéressantes notamment sur les
questions d'essai cliniques et de
participation des femmes aux essais
cliniques qui je crois ont été abordés
lors de la précédente audition
mais puisqu'on nous disposons de 10
minutes et que le temps file souvent
très vite et que ce soit la question de
la santé des femmes au travail que vous
m'interrogez je me suis permise de
structurer mon propos autour de trois
points alors j'avais un diaporama qui ne
fonctionne pas mais on va faire les
choses à l'ancienne et ça ira très bien
aussi le premier point que je voulais
développer à titre introductif mais pour
poser on va dire un cadre de
compréhension c'est le fait que ce qui
frappe quand on croise ces deux domaines
de la santé et du travail c'est le fait
que les femmes y sont largement
invisibilisés et essentiellement pour
des raisons historiques vous m'avez vous
l'avez rappelé je suis historienne donc
moi c'est cette perspective là que
j'adopte le plus souvent et donc il y a
des raisons historiques à cette
invisibilisation du domaine du travail
et du domaine de la santé pour ce qui
concerne les femmes
pour dire les choses rapidement
l'androocentrisme des savoirs médicaux
qui sont pensés par et pour les hommes
et qui font que le corps standard pour
la médecine ça a longtemps été le corps
d'un homme c'est des choses qui sont
largement démontrées par les travaux
historiques qui ont été aussi rappelés
je crois lors de l'audition du 17
novembre dernier avec l'exemple des
études très cliniques et des études
cliniques avec l'exemple des recherches
pharmaceutiques même si il y a eu
beaucoup d'évolution favorables et que
il y a des choses très remarquables de
ce point de vue là qui se sont passés on
est aujourd'hui presque à parité pour ce
qui est la participation des femmes aux
essais cliniques c'est important de le
souligner mais moi j'aime à rappeler il
y a des curiosités et c'est rappeler
c'est indiqué dans le rapport de la
Haute Autorité de Santé par exemple vous
avez 76% des participants à des études
cliniques dans le domaine de
l'ophtalmologie qui sont des femmes
alors qu'il n'y a pas de femmes
participant aux études cliniques dans un
domaine des produits de contraste pour
l'imagerie médicale c'est les chiffres
qui sont dans le rapport de la Haute
Autorité de Santé et qui sont assez
curieux je trouve parce que évidemment
le domaine de l'ophtalmologie laisse un
peu pensif dans la mesure où les yeux
sont quand même un organe pour la peine
assez peu j'en ai et pourtant on a cette
curiosité de sur-repréesation féminine
donc il y a encore des points sur
lesquels il faut progresser mais il y a
eu des évolutions favorables je crois
que c'est important de le dire et puis
il y a aussi pour ce qui est
l'invisibilisation des femmes en santé
l'exemple qui est désormais canonique
des maladies cardiovasculaires et des
symptomatiques que présente la moitié
des femmes qui font par exemple un
infarctus du myocarde et pour terminer
sur ce point rapidement on a donc
largement montré par l'histoire que les
femmes sont mal diagnostiquées que les
femmes sont mal soignées et que c'est
surtout parce qu'elles sont invisibles
ou alors parce qu'elles sont
survisibilisées mais sur certaines
spécificités par exemple la santé
sexuelle et reproductive fait l'objet
d'un intérêt particulier mais on oublie
souvent comme j'aime à le rappeler à mes
étudiants en médecine que les femmes ont
aussi effectivement un coeur un cerveau
des poumons et effectivement sont pas
réductibles à leur fonction sexuelle et
reproductive cette invisibilité qu'on
repère dans le domaine de la santé on la
repère aussi dans le monde du travail
qui n'a pas entendu dire un jour que les
femmes avaient commencé à travailler à
partir de la première guerre mondiale
moi j'enseigne l'histoire j'entends ça
très souvent parfois même c'est la
seconde guerre mondiale alors c'est
parfaitement faux évidemment les femmes
ayant toujours travaillé on ne reviendra
pas ici sur la différence qu'il y a
entre travail et salariat mais c'est
aussi parfaitement révélateur cette idée
que les femmes ont commencé à travailler
au moment de la première guerre mondiale
puisque aujourd'hui le taux d'emploi des
femmes il est presque de 70% pour la
tranche des 15 64 ans
et bien malgré ce taux d'emploi élevé on
prend rarement la mesure de leur
participation
au monde du travail sauf peut-être quand
par exemple au cœur de la crise
sanitaire on s'est rendu compte qu'elle
formait le gros des travailleurs de
première ligne mais surtout et vous
l'avez dit on mesure moins mal la
pénibilité des emplois que les femmes
occupent et pour quelles raisons et bien
parce que il existe dans notre pays des
emplois dit féminins donc là j'exprime
les guillemets et je les mets aussi
visuellement
un exemple le métier d'infirmière c'est
des femmes à 88%
dans 88% des situations et comme ces
emplois sont perçus comme féminins on
imagine qu'ils sont donc naturellement
exercés par les femmes comprendre par là
que les femmes sont faites pour les
exercer qu'elles ont les qualités
requises pour le faire et ça c'est un
mécanisme qui est tout à fait documenté
en sociologie des professions considérer
qu'un travail requiert des qualités pour
être fait plutôt que des compétences va
se référer c'est référé à l'inné plutôt
qu'à l'acquis et ça empêche de prendre
la mesure tant du niveau de
qualification qui est requis que du
niveau de pénibilité qui est associé au
travail et ça c'est effectivement des
mécanismes intellectuels qui sont
importants
le deuxième point sur lequel je serai
beaucoup plus rapide parce que vous en
avez dit beaucoup dès votre réduction
c'est le fait que sur la santé des
femmes en général on a longtemps pas su
ou alors en a longtemps mal su et sur la
santé des femmes au travail on sait
encore mal voire pas vous avez rappelé
effectivement qu'on communique souvent
sur la baisse du chiffre des accidents
de travail et vous avez très justement
souligné que quand on regarde les choses
dans le détail la baisse effectivement
concerne les hommes alors que
l'augmentation est considérable
effectivement c'est 40% d'augmentation
chez les femmes et considérable et là
aussi ça s'explique ça s'explique alors
d'abord parce que certains métiers
masculins ont connu des baisses
défectifs comme dans le domaine de
l'industrie du bois de la chimie de la
métallurgie ça c'est tout le travail
absolument indispensable de Florence
chaper et de la natte que vous avez
évoqué mais ça s'explique aussi par
ailleurs parce que les femmes sont de
plus en plus nombre sur le marché de
l'emploi et qu'elle rentre dans des
secteurs comme la santé ou le social ou
le risque d'accident du travail est
largement sous-estimé et aussi où on
travaille peu et c'est le dernier
exemple que je vais développer sur la
question des conditions de travail et
évidemment ces conditions de travail
au-delà de la nature des emplois
exercés elles sont déterminantes donc
j'étais à déterminerai pour tenir mon
temps puisqu'il me reste trois minutes
en développant un exemple qui est
extrêmement révélateur de ce que je
viens de vous expliquer et je trouve que
parfois un bon exemple vaut mieux que
beaucoup de théories c'est l'exemple des
troubles musculo-squelettiques
alors quelques chiffres pour commencer
vous l'avez rappelé c'est la première
maladie professionnelle dans notre pays
c'est 88% des 50000 malades ont été
reconnues
atteint d'une maladie professionnelle en
2018 et
l'ensemble sur l'ensemble de ces malades
on a 55 % de malades qui sont des femmes
donc il y a une forte sur-représentation
effectivement des femmes dans le domaine
des troubles musculo-squelettiques comme
parfois chiffrer les choses ça leur
donne on va dire une ampleur plus
considérable je vous donnerai peut-être
deux chiffres le coût direct des
troubles musculo-squelettiques pour les
entreprises telles qu''évaluées par
l'assurance maladie il est de 2
milliards d'euros et les coûts indirects
sont probablement deux à cette fois plus
élevés si on réfléchit en termes de
perte de production en termes
d'absentéisme ou en termes d'impact sur
les autres employés puis évidemment il y
a un effet domino quand les personnels
commencent à s'absenter la charge de
travail elle se redéploie sur celles et
ceux qui sont malgré tout présents alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a une
surexposition féminine en matière de
troubles musculaires squelettiques
d'abord j'aime à la rappeler et c'était
sur ma diapo mais peut-être que je
parviendra à ce que je vous envoie quand
même pour les rapporteurs on diaporama
d'abord évidemment il y a des facteur
physique les causes physiques doivent
pas être négligées il y a bien sûr des
différences entre le corps des femmes et
le corps des hommes mais les corps les
facteurs physiques ne suffisent pas pour
comprendre cette surexposition et les
TMS je les prends comme exemple parce
que c'est vraiment un miroir grossissant
de l'inadaptation du monde du travail
aux femmes alors les facteurs physiques
c'est la répétition de gestes à des
cadences rapides qui sont un élément
effectivement déterminant si vous
rajoutez à ça une posture pénible un
poste mal adapté ça c'est les conditions
de travail et le poste est d'autant plus
mal adapté peut éventuellement l'outil
travail n'a pas été pensé pour qu'une
femme s'y installe bien sûr et que vous
faites tout ça dans le cadre d'un
contrat précaire avec un temps partiel
subi par exemple ou des horaires décalés
et cette fois ci c'est pas de condition
de travail que je vous parle mais de
conditions d'emploi
et que vous articulez encore ça à une
vie personnelle qui est dense parfois
compliquée bon et là on parle
aujourd'hui d'articulation des temps de
vie et bien vous avez un cocktail si
vous passez l'expression qui devient
explosif effectivement le travail fait
mal et d'autant plus mal quand ces
conditions là s'installent dans le temps
quand ces conditions-là dure or c'est le
cas pour les femmes puisque on sait que
moins les salariés ont perspective
d'évolution professionnelle plus elles
ont un risque de TMS qui augmente or
précisément on le repère en sociologie
des professions dans les métiers qu'on
dit féminins des progressions de
carrière sont plus rares et le plafond
de verre existe encore et donc fait que
ces femmes qui sont en condition de
travail et en conditions d'emplois
difficiles elles y restent et donc les
troubles musculo-squelettiques s'en
trouvent augmentés par ailleurs ces
troubles musculoosquelettiques il se
manifeste en différé ça c'est aussi des
choses qui ont été largement démontré et
donc il faudrait en quelque sorte vous
l'avez évoqué travailler davantage à des
politiques de prévention et
à la rate une discussion que j'avais une
avec une personne à la rate qui
m'indiquait que il faut faire attention
à ce qu'elles appellent des signaux
faibles c'est-à-dire que l'absentéisme
c'est une alerte jaune par exemple des
restrictions d'aptitudes
délivrée par la médecine du travail
c'est l'alerte orange et finalement
quand la reconnaissance aux maladies
professionnelles survient c'est trop
tard on est déjà on est déjà dans le
rouge et donc là on a des problématiques
spécifiques pour les femmes sur leur
lieu de travail qui encore une fois sont
souvent invisibles mal comprise
sous-évalué pour toutes les raisons que
j'ai évoquées dans mon introduction et
pour terminer et pour conclure en tenant
mon temps j'aimerais rappeler ce que dit
Karen Messing qui est une ergonome
québécoise qui a fait un travail tout à
fait remarquable sur ces métiers
féminins et qui dit que le travail léger
pèse lourd et que effectivement les
femmes parce qu'elles semblent épargnées
par les métiers qui sont connus pour
être pénibles et dangereux sont
finalement en dehors des radars et que
c'est la raison pour lesquelles et ben
le travail leur fait particulièrement
mal mais si vous me le permettez et pour
terminer sur une note positive
j'aimerais dire que la prise en
considération dans le monde du travail
des souffrances spécifiques et le
déploiement de solutions concrètes est
évidemment bénéfique aux femmes ça on
démontre mais surtout surtout pas
surtout mais aussi
bénéfique à l'ensemble des personnes qui
travaillent je signale par exemple à
votre attention cette évolution qui
n'est plus tout à fait restante à La
Poste à la poste par exemple donc depuis
que la distribution du courrier est
assurée aussi par des femmes le chariot
à roulette a remplacé la besace et ça a
fait l'objet de travaux intéressants sur
les conséquences en termes de santé au
travail alors il y a eu la distance de
la part des facteurs à l'ancienne si je
puis dire pour lequel pour lesquelles la
besace était finalement un objet
symbolique mais on documente le fait que
depuis que chariot à roulette a remplacé
la besace et bien la santé du dos et des
épaules des factrices et aussi des
facteurs s'emportent bien mieux alors
conclusion prendre en considération les
problématiques des femmes au travail ça
leur serait évidemment bénéfique au
premier chef mais ça serait certainement
aussi bénéfique de manière générale à
une amélioration des conditions de
travail et des conditions d'emploi pour
les femmes et pour les hommes je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup
madame salles donc pour cette première
intervention qui nous éclaire à la fois
sur le travail des femmes pendant toutes
ces dernières années et puis sur les
conditions dans lesquelles les femmes
exercent vous avez eu un éclairage
extrêmement intéressant sur à la fois
statistique et sur la présentation de ce
travail donc je vais peut-être laisser
la parole aux rapporteur si elle
souhaite vous questionner avant de
passer à la deuxième intervenante
puisque vous devez nous quitter dans un
quart d'heure si j'ai bien compris donc
nous avons les quatre apporteurs avec
nous ici en présentiel je ne sais pas
s'il y a des questions ou des réactions
peut-être par rapport à l'intervention
de Madame salle ou sinon on passera
directement Marie-Pierre tu me regardes
Marie-Pierre Richer un porteur
je voulais pas prendre la parole la
première comme je l'ai prise la dernière
fois je l'essai il y a pas d'ordre
de passage vous êtes à égalité
merci Madame pour pour vos propos j'ai
suivi aussi en parallèle cette semaine
un peu vos interventions puisque je
savais que on vous auditionnait ce matin
j'ai deux questions très rapide la
première de quelle façon la crise
sanitaire a participé à dégrader les
conditions de travail des femmes
parce que je suppose que c'est que c'est
le cas comme elles étaient quand même
dans de nombreux métiers dit en première
ligne et à votre avis quels sont les
leviers à actionner à court et moyen
terme pour améliorer les
la qualité de vie au travail on en parle
beaucoup mais mais dans quelle mesure
elles ont constitué une avancée pour les
femmes dans l'histoire merci
on vous laisse répondre à cette question
vous n'avez pas le micro on dirait là
dans quelle mesure est-ce que la crise
sanitaire a dégradé les conditions de
travail pour les femmes alors c'est vous
faire une réponse rapide sur un sujet
aussi complexe me paraîtrait un peu
problématique mais pour dire les choses
rapidement alors évidemment d'abord le
fait que les femmes soient sur
représentées dans les professions de
santé qui ont été
exposées au premier chef à évidemment je
dirais augmenter l'attention sur sur ces
professions là
j'ajouterai en tant que universitaire
qui a assuré la continuité pédagogique
que là on articule à la fois continuité
de service public et télétravail moi
j'ai télétravaillé pendant toute la
période du confinement on était en
confiné seul avec deux jeunes enfants
donc là on a à la fois la question de
travailler en présence dans des
conditions dégradées puis dans des
conditions de stress important et et
puis pour ce qui me concerne et je suis
pas représentative évidemment moi toute
seule les conséquences je pense encore
assez mal mesuré du télétravail sur la
santé physique on pourrait parler
lumbago par exemple mais aussi sur la
santé mentale sur lesquels en tout cas
on est actuel voilà il y a des travaux
qui sont en train de s'élaborer mais on
est en train de prendre la mesure et
peut-être sur ce point-là si vous me le
permettez moi ce qui me frappe c'est la
façon dont quand le travail est repris
en condition je dirais normal il y a eu
finalement très peu de réflexions sur ce
qui s'était passé ce qui avait été vécu
par les femmes voilà qui travaillaient
dans ces conditions-là de la crise
sanitaire mais mais plus globalement par
les gens qui ont qui n'ont pas cessé
travailler alors il y a des travaux qui
sont en cours mais pour l'instant on
attend un petit peu on attend un petit
peu les résultats
pour ce qui est des leviers à actionner
ben moi je crois que par exemple
introduire de manière systématique le
concept de genre qui est celui auquel je
tiens moi beaucoup pour analyser les
politiques publiques qui sont déployées
en matière de santé ou en matière par
exemple
de d'incitation à l'emploi ou au retour
à l'emploi
utiliser ce concept de genre de manière
systématique pour évaluer les politiques
publiques ça ça pourrait être vraiment
quelque chose d'intéressant par exemple
considérer que les politiques de
prévention en matière de santé au
travail
ne sont aujourd'hui que peu ou pas j'en
rêvais et peut-être accompagné à ce
titre là la formation des inspecteurs et
des inspectives du travail ça pourrait
présenter un intérêt tout à fait tout à
fait concret et puis moi ce qui reste
mon cheval de bataille mais voilà c'est
la informations des professionnels de
santé et en l'occurrence moi je forme
des médecins c'est d'ailleurs des
médecins que je retrouve à 10h à des
étudiants en médecine je sais
d'expérience que la formation sur ces
questions de santé des femmes ou on va
dire de santé au prisme du genre elle
est
anecdotique dans notre pays en général
et dans les cursus médicaux en
particulier et que pour ce qui est de la
formation des médecins du travail c'est
quelque chose qui est complètement
absent et que par exemple le travail des
ergonomes que j'ai cité tout à l'heure
mériterait largement de faire partie du
bagage de base je crois des médecins du
travail
merci le micro moi donc une autre
question de notre collègue rapporteur
Laurence Rossignol bonjour Muriel salle
de deux questions la première qui fait
suite à ce que vous venez de dire sur
votre activité de formatrice dans les
études de médecine je sais vous êtes à
Nantes c'est ça
à Lyon
alors je sais qu'à Nantes il existe une
formation dans l'étude de médecine vous
dites à Lyon est-ce que cette formation
elle est commune
à tous les étudiants en médecine quels
sont les universités qu'il a pratiquent
et celles qui ne la pratique pas et
comment peut-on nous porter la nécessité
d'une inclusion dans les études de
médecine du type de formation que vous
évoquez ça c'est ma première question ma
deuxième question est-ce que vous avez
eu l'occasion est-ce que des travaux ont
pu quantifier et évaluer l'impact de
de la méconnaissance on va dire de la
non prise en compte
de la question spécifique de la santé
des femmes au travail sur l'égalité
salariale et l'égalité professionnelle
aller de l'urssa je sais c'est si ça n'a
pas été fait c'est pas compliqué vous me
dit on n'a pas travaillé dessus c'est
compliqué voilà
[Musique]
être capable c'est comme ça que les
choses avaient ont été dites à Patricia
donc ça illustre un peu les choses moi à
Lyon je voudrais surtout pas vous donner
l'impression que je fais la révolution à
Lyon je fais une matinée d'enseignement
en première année
de d'études de santé sur les questions
de sexe et de gens en santé parce que
moi je sais pas le propos aujourd'hui
mais je crois la nécessité d'articuler
ces deux concepts là d'une part et puis
j'interviens aussi mais là encore
ponctuellement un coup de deux heures
ici trois heures par là au niveau des
masters par exemple dans des masters en
santé publique ou dans des masters en
anthropologie du soin donc c'est pas on
va dire dans dans le cadre je dirais du
dur de la formation le problème étant et
c'est pour ça que votre question est
tout à fait pertinente comment
pourrait-on faire pour inscrire ces
questions là au curriculum puisque en
fait les programmations elles sont
décidées par les universités c'est bien
au niveau local que les choses se
décident il n'y a pas de nationale pour
les études de médecine il n'y a pas de
plan grand plan national ça c'est pas
centralisé il y a un moment où
l'ensemble des étudiants et des
étudiants en médecine se mesure les uns
et les autres au plan national ce moment
de l'internat et donc du coup si on veut
être efficace il faut inscrire ces
questions là
de genre en santé dans les questions qui
sont préparées par les étudiants dans le
cas de l'internat qu'on appelle aussi
les l'Examen Classant National parce que
là vous avez un programme national et
donc là et par ailleurs l'enjeu de
l'internat est tel que si vous inscrivez
les choses au programme de l'internat
des étudiants et les étudiants
travailleront sur ces sujets là et en
l'occurrence se verront forcément offrir
une formation préalable donc ça c'est
voilà pour moi je pense que le levier en
réalité le seul levier qu'on est
véritablement pour faire évoluer des
curriculums en santé c'est c'est
celui-ci et puis pour votre question ben
non j'ai pas de réponse mais je ne
manquerai pas d'essayer de voir si on
peut pas mettre des étudiants sur le
sujet voilà
souvent les obligations de ces
multinationales ou de ces ETI sont un
peu plus poussées et donc les amènent
peut-être à avancer plus rapidement sur
ces sujets de conditions de travail et
de répondre à des postes enfin de
d'avoir des postes de travail qui
permettent de faire attention à ces
difficultés à cette pénibilité je vous
remercie mais mais oui bien sûr
évidemment que la taille de l'entreprise
à avoir avec alors avec la prise en
compte des problématiques de santé au
travail mais de manière plus générale
puisque c'est ce qui intéresse la
délégation avec l'avancée
d'une réflexion sur les questions
d'égalité famome dans le monde du
travail parce que parce que les grandes
entreprises ont les moyens de se doter
de consultants extérieurs qui leur
élaborent des plans
égalité parce que les entreprises des
entreprises effectivement de de grandes
tailles sont aujourd'hui en plus dans le
texte actuel particulièrement sensible à
mettre en avant la qualité de vie au
travail pour des raisons de recrutement
et donc c'est une façon aujourd'hui de
se rendre attractif pour ses entreprises
donc oui et bien sûr la difficulté c'est
les petites entreprises ou les
travailleurs les travailleurs
indépendants je trouve que je travaille
à l'heure actuelle avec l'ordre des
avocats de de la de Lyon typiquement les
questions de à la fois de santé au
travail et d'égalité professionnelle
quand on est dans un cabinet où il y a
il y a deux ou trois éventuellement
collaborateurs on manque de moyens
humains on manque de moyens
administratifs et donc et donc oui bien
sûr on est d'autant plus invisible qu'on
est dans une entreprise de taille
modeste voir de petites tailles et vous
avez raison c'est c'est quand même le
gros de la structure de l'emploi dans le
pays alors cette question sera inspiré
une autre intervention de la rapporteur
Annick Jake je pense qu'après on vous
libérera madame
max merci Madame ma présidente oui
concernant les troubles
musculo-squelettiques je sais qui a
souvent des formations qui sont
proposées notamment dans les cartes dans
les carrières dans les EHPAD dans les
dans tous ces métiers où il faut porter
est-ce que vous avez un retour justement
entre les formations qui sont dispensées
et l'amélioration après parce que les
habitudes ont la vie dure et quand on a
l'habitude à certains gestes c'est
parfois difficile de les changer et ce
que vous pensez pas que il faudrait
aussi avoir un enseignement au gestes
aux postures dès le plus jeune âge et je
pense notamment au cours d'éducation
physique qui se font dans les collèges
et les lycées parce que finalement vous
l'avez dit une femme c'est plusieurs
plusieurs
tâches dans une même journée et entre
les courses portes et les gamins les
charges
pas que les charges au travail est-ce
que ça contribue pas aussi finalement à
user les organismes et que apprendre à
soulever ne serait-ce que ça en baisse
en les genoux et pas en pliant le dos ça
pourrait aussi améliorer la santé des
femmes en règle générale non ça pourrait
je vous remercie pour cette question ça
pourrait être une effectivement une
bonne idée peut-être pour faire évoluer
les les programmes d'enseignement
d'éducation physique et sportive par
ailleurs vous mettez le doigt sur encore
un autre problème et je trouve que en
plus de former des médecins je forme des
enseignants et donc je sais d'expérience
que les jeunes filles se désengagent de
la pratique physique et sportive en
dehors des cours obligatoires on le sait
au documentait à partir de la fin du
collège et encore quelques années
aujourd'hui on document que le fait que
se désengagement il est précoce à partir
de la classe de 5e se désengager ça veut
dire quoi ne plus y aller du tout soit y
aller mais en étant tout à fait démotivé
en y prenant pas pas du tout une partie
et ça ça avoir avec des stéréotypes très
ancrées sur la question des femmes et
des pratiques sportives mais c'est un
autre sujet donc oui évidemment
peut-être apprendre à prendre soin de
son corps d'ailleurs pour les pour les
filles et pour les femmes comme pour les
garçons pour les hommes ça pourrait être
une très bonne idée et pour ramasser
vraiment ma réponse à votre première
question l'impact des formations il est
peut-être mesuré mais pour l'instant en
tout cas à ma connaissance on n'a pas
suffisamment de recul pour
avoir on va dire des éléments
significatifs à aborder ce qui ressort
souvent de la façon dont ces formations
sont vécues c'est que les gestes qu'il
est demandé d'effectuer augmente
la durée
de la tâche qu'on doit effectuer quand
on et que donc très souvent vous avez
dit non seulement les habitudes ont la
vie dure mais les cadences de travail
font que entre ce que le des formateur
ou la formatrice prescrit et ce qu'il
est véritablement possible de faire
sur le long terme dans le cadre de sa
pratique professionnelle il y a parfois
loin
voilà ce que je pourrais vous dire
et bien écoutez madame je vous remercie
pour les réponses que vous avez pu
apporter à nos collègues rapporteurs on
va vous libérer et laisser vous laisser
aller travailler j'espère avec de bonnes
conditions de travail et des postes
adaptés voilà merci à vous bonne journée
à vous on va pour on va poursuivre nos
audition de ce matin avec vous Madame
Caroline Pau qui a écrit également comme
de nombreuses intervenants de ce matin
un livre que vous m'avez offert la santé
des femmes un guide pour comprendre les
enjeux et agir donc que je vais prendre
je vais prendre je vais en prendre
connaissance très rapidement je vous
remercie et je le ferai circuler avec
les rapporteurs bien entendu merci je
vous laisse la parole madame merci
pardonnez-moi pour ma voix je pense que
j'ai un petit un petit virus qui est
contre un peu donc je vais je vais faire
l'effort j'avais un petit diaporama je
ne sais pas si je sais que j'ai de quoi
le passé les diapos mais j'ai pas de
quoi le lancer peut-être
et en tout cas merci de m'avoir invité
je suis honorée d'être là et j'espère
que je vais vous amener les éléments
utiles mais j'ai aucun doute aussi que
Madame boulet viendra rebondir dessus
oui ça va bien je vais bien avec
non après tu voulais je peux mettre un
masque mais ça ne s'appelle pas le covid
il s'appelle une pharyngite du coup ça
va
[Musique]
vous laisser ça vous pouvez même faire
un câlin ça marche bien
en attendant que vous lancez je vais
commencer et puis comme ça je vais je
vais
on me rattrapera en route avec le
diaporama voilà moi je vais vous parler
de ma double posture à savoir je suis
sociologue et je dirige l'Union
régionale des médecins libéraux des
Hauts-de-France donc ça me permet de
vous parler de de cette de cette
position là vous rappelez que vu que
vous êtes sûr sans téléphone au travail
on ne peut absolument pas dissocier un
effet la santé du travail puisque
l'OMS définissant la santé comme un état
de bien-être physique mental et social
qui ne consiste pas seulement une
absence de maladie ou d'infirmité et qui
a prêté complété avec une définition
avec la charte d'Ottawa qui donne
notamment comme ressources préalable
pour être en bonne santé se loger
accéder à l'éducation se nourrir
convenablement disposer d'un certain
revenu bénéficier d'un écosystème stable
compter sur un apport durable de
ressources et avoir le droit à la
justice sociale et un traitement
équitable vous doutez bien que sur
toutes ces dimensions qui sont des
préalables pour être en la santé le
travail est une valeur pivot donc je
suis je suis ravi d'être là aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir en échanger avec vous je
sais que vous avez vu madame Vidal et
j'ai beaucoup de respect on a aussi
collaboré ensemble donc je vais pas vous
refaire les chiffres qu'elle a pu vous
donner il y a trois semaines notamment
en termes de désespérance de vie de
décalage et d'espérance de vie en bonne
santé par contre ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant à savoir c'est pourquoi on
parle de la santé au travail et vous
avez demandé un peu des chiffres
les femmes sont défavorisées en matière
de conditions et de ressources
préalables notamment en précarité
financière immédiate et à distance c'est
à dire qu'elles sont plus à subir le
chômage subi donc pas choisi elles sont
moins bien rémunérées et quand elles
sont dans une situation de parentalité
elles sont pénalisées et quand il y a un
conjoint homme la femme est plus
pénalisée que l'homme en terme de
rémunération
elle subissent plus de temps partiel
subit il y a quatre fois plus de temps
partiel chez les femmes par exemple
les chefs de
et que entre guillemets les enfants sont
éloignés mais non l'écart l'écart
continue et le plafond le plafond de
verre et bien et bien présent sur le
sujet et je redébattrai de ce sujet là
avec vous mais j'ai tendance à militer
aussi pour ne pas prendre en compte que
les catégories socio-professionnelles
mais bien le sexe aussi le lieu de
résidence l'origine géographique vu
qu'on parle de travail le statut
familial est donc de penser la santé
comme un modelage par la position
sociale occupée par par la personne
après de manière un peu provocatrice sur
le diapo que vous n'avez pas je vous
avais mis un schéma qui date de 98 qui a
été fait par le Haut Conseil des
Antilles publiques de l'époque et qui
montrait les les enchaînements causaux
de la mauvaise santé en situation de
précarité qui montrait bien déjà des
choses qu'on connaît de l'inbric de
l'intrication entre chômage et précarité
du travail dégradation des conditions de
vie en quoi ça va engendrer de la
souffrance psy logique une vulnérabilité
accrue une mauvaise santé physique et
mentale et comment transfo les
rapporteurs
parfait alors du coup pour les pour les
rapporteurs je suis sur ma diapo 4
et donc sur ce sur ce schéma ce qui moi
m'intéresser c'est le l'enchaînement
causal évidemment parce qu'on voit que
tout est tout est lié mais surtout il
date de 98 et j'ai l'impression de
refaire exactement le même débat
aujourd'hui et je me demande ce que ce
qu'on a pu faire depuis 1998 sur le
sujet donc pour vous dire aussi que le
phénomène les processus sont connus
depuis bien longtemps sans documenter
depuis bien longtemps et j'étais plutôt
ravie quand on m'a dit qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour améliorer les choses
plutôt que d'essayer de vous le
redéfinir une fois de plus
en termes de de pénibilité et de risques
pénibilité et risque sont évidemment
sous-estimés chez les femmes on a donné
les chiffres mais voilà il y a une
souffrance chronique qui est plus forte
qui est associée au travail par lesquels
on va retrouver l'arthrose les
lombalgies et atteintes chroniques du
dos les cervicales chroniques mais ça je
sais que Madame Vidal l'aborder avec
vous
Muriel salle en a parlé aussi en effet
nous subissons les stéréotypes de genre
sur l'imaginaire du travail féminin et
masculin et de sa pénibilité associé
c'est à dire que dans l'imaginaire
collectif on va considérer que un
travail pénible masculin et masculin par
définition et il est avec à des efforts
physiques importants avec des ports de
charge lourdes avec quelque chose qui
fait du bruit enfin moi je viens du des
Hauts de France typiquement le mineur
est un travail pénible et ben ça va être
un peu le stéréotype qu'on va avoir du
travail du travail pénible masculin ce
qui fait que il y a eu des programmes de
prévention qui ont été faits qui ont été
plutôt efficaces et très bien pour ça
mais ce qui entraîne de fait une
sous-estimation de la pénibilité
féminine et avec des programmes de
prévention beaucoup moins nombreux parce
qu'on va l'estimer moins dangereuse donc
ça c'est un premier c'est un premier
problème les TMS vous en avez parlé
beaucoup donc je vais pas vous les
redécrire vous redonner les secteurs
dans lesquels on peut les trouver
secteur de l'entretien d'aide à domicile
accueil aux caisses dans les
supermarchés les métiers ou il y a une
surregmentation féminine ça voudrait-je
faire le pont en disant que c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'on s'en occupe peu
et que si c'était des hommes qui étaient
à la place on aurait déjà fait des plans
de prévention c'est fort probable donc
il y a un certain déni qui existe des
conditions de travail de non premiers
dit dès lors qu'on les classifie comme
comme féminin et puis il y a aussi un
sujet sur la reconnaissance et la
sous-déclaration des maladies
professionnelles moi je suis plutôt
contente de voir que les chiffres
augmentent parce que ça veut dire que
les femmes se saisissent de cette
question et qu'elles assument de dire
que leurs conditions de travail est en
train de les rendre malades et
pour le coup voilà il faut prendre ces
chiffres aussi comme peut-être un
phénomène de rattrapage de conditions
déjà préexistantes et de d'une place
qu'elles sont en train de prendre parce
que pour le coup elles ont tendance à
sous-déclarer les maladies
professionnelles parce qu'elles ont peur
de perdre leur emploi quand je vous ai
donné le descriptif par exemple des
familles monoparentales vous ne pouvez
pas vous perdre vous permettre de perdre
votre emploi donc vous n'allez pas faire
une déclaration de maladie
professionnelle si vous avez peur de
vous retrouver en difficulté elles ont
peur d'un licenciement qui pourrait être
catastrophique pour elle
d'un reclassement et elle manque
d'informations les procédures
administratives sont complexes souvent
décourageantes et il y a aussi un manque
de soutien des soignants par
méconnaissance des risques évidemment
pas par volonté mais bien par une
méconnaissance de ce qui peut de ce qui
peut exister
à titre d'exemple par exemple sur le
déni des conditions de travail je
trouvais que l'exemple était un peu
édifiant
les nombreux métiers du féminin vont
avoir un portrait positif de charge qui
dépasse la norme autorisée qui est de 25
kg en l'occurrence les infirmières les
aides à domicile les ouvrières dépassent
très souvent et très largement cette
norme
donc c'est pas parce que ce sont des
faibles femmes c'est juste parce qu'on
leur donne trop de charges
sur cette pénibilité
l'invisivation des risques aussi sur les
cancers professionnels chez les femmes
les études sur les expositions alors en
effet il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
progrès sur les essais thérapeutiques et
ça c'est vraiment une bonne chose par
contre suivez dimensions recherches en
santé travail on n'y est pas du tout en
termes de hommes et femmes c'est-à-dire
que dans les recherches sur la santé
travail
on ne questionne pas le sexe et pour le
coup si on le questionne pas on n'a pas
de données et donc il est compliqué de
faire des mesures et des plans de
prévention donc elles sont souvent en
conduite chez les hommes et ça entraîne
une faiblesse dans les mesures de
protection alors que notamment dans les
métiers que je vous ai pu citer dans le
nettoyage où on a démontré que elles
peuvent être exposées jusqu'à 14 agents
cancérogènes sur leur chariots de ménage
il y a pas d'objet d'études alors que
par exemple et c'est tant mieux pour eux
dans le BTP mais il y a eu beaucoup
d'études fait sur le sujet pour
justement prévenir des risques notamment
d'exposition à des à des cancér
et puis les risques les risques
psychosociaux sont aussi des risques qui
vont toucher plus gravement les femmes
ne serait-ce que parce que ce sont des
risques qui sont plus fréquents parce
que c'est dans les métiers après
dominance féminines alors de quoi on
parle quand on parle de risques
psychosociaux c'est des risques qui sont
pour la santé physique et mentale en
lien avec le travail et dans les causes
relèvent des conditions d'emploi de
l'organisation et des relations de
travail donc c'est des risques sur
lesquels on peut agir quel que soit la
taille de l'entreprise
et donc ces risques sont
particulièrement concernés
particulièrement les femmes notamment
sur les postes peu qualifiés sur les
horaires atypiques sur le travail
fractionné ou sur le manque d'autonomie
ou les femmes sont sur représentées
je vous l'ai dit aussi plus de
discontinuité et de rupture dans les
parcours professionnels qui augmentent
les risques psychosociaux et puis une
sur-reprétation dans les secteurs
d'activité avec des relations humaines
super merci
donc ces métiers vont les confronter à
des risques c'est ça parfait merci
des risques qui sont le plus souvent
minimisés et voir occulter par celles
qui les subissent aussi c'est à dire que
les femmes sont malheureusement parfois
leur plus mauvaise défenseuse
c'est-à-dire qu'elles vont trouver que
c'est normal qu'on leur parle mal c'est
normal qu'on les maltraite elles ont
intégré ce risque comme quelque chose de
classique parce qu'elle devrait déjà ne
pas l'accepter dans leur vie personnelle
mais elle accepte aussi dans leur vie
professionnelle donc c'est tout ce qui
va être métier pour lesquels on va être
agent d'accueil où on va être
téléconseillé où on va être caissière
voilà tous ces métiers qui vivent ça
donc ça entraîne voilà tension avec les
personnes remarque sexistes demande
d'urgence pour des situations sociales
parfois dramatiques qui font que on a un
risque psychologique important
du coup je peux l'utiliser pardon merci
je vais aller très vite parce que c'est
un sujet mais c'est un sujet qui est
plutôt bien documenté et qui fait
régulièrement débat et donc je pense que
je vous apprendrai moins de choses ce
matin sur le sujet
mais le focus sur harcèlement au travail
puisque dans les dernières études c'est
une femme sur 5 une femme active qui est
au cours de sa vie professionnelle va
vivre une situation de harcèlement
sexuelle au travail et seulement une sur
20 déposera plainte on a encore aussi un
sujet de libération de la parole sur ce
que c'est un harcèlement ce qui n'est
pas mais quand il l'est qu'il soit
reconnu et
pénalisé et 80% des femmes on est sur
des chiffres qui sont importants car 80%
des femmes salariés qui considèrent
qu'elles sont régulièrement confrontées
à des études des attitudes ou des
décisions sexistes qui entraînent une
perte de confiance en soi de bien-être
au travail mais aussi de performance
puisque évidemment la confiance en soi
et aussi liée à la à la performance et à
la souffrance psychologique
et 93% des femmes qui pensent que cette
étude peuvent avoir des répercussions
sur leurs sentiments d'efficacités
personnel et donc sur leur santé mentale
je rechange des liens forts entre
charges mentales professionnelle et
domestiques et pour le coup je pense que
Madame voulait pour largement compléter
donc je vais pas aller trop trop sur ce
sujet là si vous me le permettez mais
évidemment les femmes subissent plus
fortement la transformation sociétale
des familles les couples bi actifs les
familles monoparentales recomposées le
fait d'avoir des grands-parents
dépendants les exigences éducatives
croissantes malheureusement c'est encore
aujourd'hui majoritairement les femmes
qui doivent supporter
ces activités domestiques et parentales
avec la conciliation de vie
professionnelle la pression est très
forte aussi auprès des femmes pour
endosser le rôle de proche aidant quand
on doit être notamment aide parental et
filiales c'est moins vrai quand on parle
d'une personne en situation de handicap
mais en tout cas on est de parental et
filiales c'est très flagrant et plus
vous augmentez le nombre des dents plus
la différence de genre se pose puisque
par exemple 57% des aidants sont des
femmes mais quand vous avez par exemple
les deux personnes c'est 75% des aidants
qui sont les femmes et ce qui impose de
devoir concilier sa vie privée sa vie
professionnelle et cette intégration de
schéma
se fait dès le plus jeune âge je
reviendrai dessus après mais voilà
l'évolution du marché du travail actuel
qui demande des horaires décalés d'une
disponibilité de plus en plus importante
un présentéisme qui est très français de
dire que si on est là c'est qu'on est
compétent et que si on travaille à
distance on les peut bah forcément
pénaliser un peu plus les femmes qui
sont dans la conciliation vie domestique
et vie professionnelle avec les
contraintes qui sont associées
je vous ai mis aussi l'exemple de la
fibromyalgie puisque la question c'est
est-ce qu'à un moment le travail
pourrait même rendre malade et la fibril
la fibromyalgie est un sujet qu'il faut
pouvoir aborder de manière dépasser
c'est-à-dire que la fibromyalgie c'est
symptômes c'est des douleurs musculaires
squelettiques donc ça fait un pont avec
les TMS dont on parlait et puis une
fatigue majeure chez des personnes pour
lesquelles on a éliminé tout autre cause
de symptômes
ces deux à quatre pour cent des adultes
donc c'est pas non plus anodin mais
c'est un rapport de 8 femmes pour un
homme donc on est sur un rapport
particulièrement important et le profil
type c'est des femmes travaillant dans
le secteur du social ou dans la relation
d'aide d'une quarantaine d'années et au
moment de la survenue de leur symptômes
on aurait tort de croire que entre
guillemets c'est dans la tête et que
c'est parce que elle supporte pas leur
quotidien pour le coup dans la
documentation c'est plutôt une
pathologie de la charge mentale qui qui
va toucher en particulier ces métiers
qu'on appelle les métiers du Caire dans
lequel on va t'ouvrir les médecins les
infirmières alors je les féminise
forcément et volontairement les
aides-soignantes les aides à domicile
qui pour le coup avec cet articulation
vie professionnelle vie domestique et
vie sociale vont avoir le don de soi en
permanence à assumer et fait qu'à un
moment leur condition de travail et
leurs conditions de vie vont tellement
se dégrader que il n'est plus possible
de faire quoi que ce soit donc cette
dissociation d'espace de vie privée et
de vie professionnelle et compliqué dans
ces métiers ça les expose à un risque
pour leur santé et ça atteint gravement
leur santé mentale
vous avez aussi parlé de la dépression
donc je me permettais de faire un focus
rapide parce que c'est un peu moins le
sujet entre guillemets pour pour moi
dans le sens où le problème de la
dépression c'est que c'est pas une
maladie de femme c'est une maladie qui
est sous diagnostiquée chez les hommes
et que on aurait si on intégré les
symptômes complets à savoir aussi des
pratiques addictives des conduitaristes
on aurait une égalité dans la proportion
de femmes et d'hommes dépressifs donc là
pour le coup on a un sous repérage
justement par nos stéréotype qui aurait
tendance à croire que la symptomatologie
de la dépression serait uniquement
réservée à de la fatigue de la tristesse
des pleurs alors que si vous englobez
les autres on serait un équivalent sur
les hommes et les femmes donc ce qui
pose un sujet en effet du comment on va
aussi aller repérer et accompagner les
hommes qui qui sont pour le coup là en
situation de défaveur entre guillemets
si je peux me permettre sur le repérage
de ce de ce sujet
en sachant que la dépression n'est donc
pas un problème d'hormones mais bien un
problème de société et de précarité
c'est pas parce qu'on a les hormones qui
chatouille qui font des primes c'est
parce qu'on a une vie qui est un peu
difficile à concilier et que quand je
vous ai montré par exemple le premier
schéma sur les conditions de vie et le
fait que les femmes soient plus exposées
à cette précarité forcément
votre vie est plus difficile si vous
vous demandez si vous allez faire vivre
votre famille à la fin de la semaine que
si tout va bien pour vous
j'ai presque voilà j'ai presque terminé
pourquoi on en arrive à cette situation
là c'est évidemment pas
inné assez c'est beaucoup c'est acquis
c'est qu'on intègre un discours
dissuasif pour accéder à certains postes
et la nécessité de prévoir une
trajectoire professionnelle compatible
avec les stéréotypes d'une vie de couple
et de famille idéalisée
c'est-à-dire je m'explique depuis que
elles sont toutes petites la plupart des
petites filles entendent que elles
devront être maman quels seront des
bonnes épouses et que elles auront un
métier qui sera compatible avec ça et ce
qui fait que au moment même de le
choisir elles ne vont pas s'autoriser à
aller sur des métiers qui seraient avec
des carrières importantes et elles vont
au moment de faire des choix dire mais
je ne peux pas faire ces études là où je
ne peux pas faire ce métier là parce que
lorsque je serai maire parce que lorsque
je serai femme ma vie ne sera pas
compatible avec une vie professionnelle
avec une vie de famille telle que je
l'imagine et on va avoir donc une
auto-censure des jeunes filles qui sur
ce sur ce sujet là
vous précisez aussi qu'évidemment toutes
les femmes ne sont pas identiques qu'il
y en a malheureusement qui vont cumuler
les vulnérabilités je vous ai mis deux
exemples mais on aurait beaucoup
d'autres je vous ai mis l'exemple de la
grossophobie puisque c'est un sujet
aussi mais si vous êtes et femmes et en
situation de surpoids et d'obésité vous
avez malheureusement
moins de chance que les autres c'est à
dire que vous aurez tendance à accéder
moins aux études parce que vous allez
vos options censurées parce que votre
estime ne vous même elle aura été
tellement
touché que vous ne vous sentez plus
capable de faire des études vous allez
être discriminés sur le marché de
l'emploi parce que même cette
discrimination existe pour les deux elle
est plus forte chez les femmes et à des
seuils de poids plus inférieurs que pour
les hommes et après alors qu'on observe
un nivellement au niveau des hommes en
termes une fois intégrés dans le milieu
professionnel les femmes en situation de
surpoids et d'obésité vont continuer à
cumuler le cette vulnérabilité
puisqu'elles vont être pénalisées en
termes de rémunération est ascension par
rapport à leurs homologues fém qui
serait plus mince donc ça ça me semble
important de le dire et puis
qu'évidemment si vous êtes femme avec
une situation de handicap vous êtes
aussi victime de double stéréotypes ceux
qui sont associés aux gens et ceux qui
sont associés aux handicap
donc pour moi voilà la nécessité de
promouvoir la mixité des métiers alors
moi je suis ravi que on se félicite que
les femmes occupent des métiers d'hommes
et je serai ravi que les hommes occupent
des métiers de femmes
parce que cette réciproque n'est
absolument pas vrai et que finalement je
vous l'ai mis après dans les diapos mais
le fait qu'une profession soit féminine
induit et j'en suis la première désolé
un déclassement de la profession je
travaille aujourd'hui pour les médecins
libéraux et toutes les analyses en effet
de trajectoire avec montre que les
études ce féminisent je me tant mieux ou
même pas d'ailleurs mais par contre ce
qu'on observe aussi c'est que les
conditions de travail se dégradent et
que si elle se féminisent cette
profession c'est peut-être d'abord parce
que les conditions de travail se
dégradent et que finalement
on le regarde par exemple sur les
trajectoires si c'est sur les
trajectoire par exemple des jeunes
étudiants les jeunes étudiants garçons
maintenant préfèrent aller sur des
filières type commerce et ingénierie qui
sont plus rémunératrices avec tes
conditions plus faciles que sur les
métiers de la santé et notamment les
métiers médicaux donc ce qu'on observait
sur les métiers on obtient aussi sur la
sur la médecine et donc voilà promouvoir
la mixité des métiers et y compris voilà
des métiers de dit de femmes occupés par
des hommes et c'est des stéréotypes qui
sont peu conscientes par les concernés
c'est-à-dire que la personne n'est
responsable de la situation on les a
tellement intériorisés que finalement on
prend conscience ou pense ça permet déjà
de changer les choses donc moi je suis
plutôt extrêmement positive sur le sujet
c'est pour ça que je suis là ce matin
c'est que je pense que dès lors qu'on en
prend conscience on est déjà plus pareil
donc développer les parcours aussi pour
limiter les phénomènes d'usure
professionnelle puisque les femmes qui
rentrent dans les postes de premier
niveau
vont avoir après peu de perspectives
d'évolution
je crois que j'en ai plus que deux ouais
c'est ça
je sais pas combien de temps j'ai encore
terminé
je vous avais mis
quelque chose qui me semblait
intéressant puisqu'on est vraiment sur
le travail quelque chose qui est pas
spécifique
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui depuis 93
on a documenté aussi les facteurs de
risque de précarité qui sont notamment
liés au social et par exemple avoir
l'absence d'autonomie dans son travail
le sentiment de ne pas utiliser toutes
ces compétences le sentiment de ne pas
recevoir l'estime que l'on pense mériter
l'absence d'estime de soi et le
sentiment de dévalorisation personnelle
sont des facteurs de risque documentés
de précarité et donc avec un impact sur
les inégalités sociales de santé fortes
et que quand je donne mes cours je
Blaise toujours pour un jour pour aller
donner ses cours dans les écoles de
management pour que les futurs managers
intègrent ces dimensions dans dans leur
encadrement puisque là pour le coup on
parle vraiment de manière de traiter
l'autre dans les relations au travail
et puis j'arrive plus à passer la diapo
j'arrive plus à passer la diapo
c'est bon merci sur les ouvertures voilà
moi je vous ai développé les recherches
genre santé travail avec des
rapprochements avec les facteurs
environnementaux au sens large avec un
focus sur les risques émergents les
nouvelles normes pour prendre en compte
les différences morphologiques en effet
le corps des femmes et corps des hommes
ne sont pas tous identiques mais
finalement c'est prendre en compte les
corps tout court parce qu'il y a des
hommes petits il y a des hommes gros et
que il y a des hommes dit normaux que
j'aimerais bien qu'on me présente mais
en tout cas finalement adapté le travail
à la morphologie des gens c'est ce que
disait Muriel salle ça sert à tout le
monde en fait ça ne sert pas que aux
femmes particulièrement diffuser la
connaissance des risques professionnels
auprès des femmes
inciter en milieu de travail à des
organisations de temps de travail plus
inclusives c'est à dire comment on peut
concilier vie professionnelle vie
personnelle et familial reconnaître les
pathologies mentales et la souffrance
psychologiques comme des accidents de
travail voire des maladies
professionnelles parce que c'est aussi
un problème de reconnaissance et puis je
vous l'ai mis aussi congé menstruel
endométriose qui sont quand même des
technologie ou des situations
particulièrement féminines à tout le
moins
mais finalement la question c'est plutôt
de dire comment on prend en compte la
douleur dans l'adaptation au travail
j'espère que un homme qui a une
pathologie pour laquelle il souffre on
adaptera aussi son poste de travail donc
peut-être de dépasser certains débats
pour en faire des questions qui sont
beaucoup plus larges dire comment on
prend en compte la douleur vous avez pas
du télétravail mais en effet comment on
place le télétravail avec des conditions
qui sont moins favorables aujourd'hui
pour les femmes en effet non seulement
parce que elles ont moins accès aux
outils numériques quand vous êtes deux à
télétravailler souvent c'est la femme
qui a pas accès à l'ordinateur et c'est
monsieur qui le gardent elles maîtrise
moins les outils numériques l'espace
dédié à la maison est souvent plus
restreint quand il est pour les femmes
et évidemment elles vont avoir la charge
familiale à assumer en même temps que
leur télétravail une flexibilité
horaires qui va être particulièrement
forte et donc le télétravail aujourd'hui
pour ces raisons là peut être
particulièrement pénalisant pour pour
les femmes et puis
attention à la confusion de définition
de féminisation des professions
pour dans le cadre de mon travail
j'entends régulièrement que le problème
c'est que les professions se féminisent
non par exemple quand on dit que la
profession féministe chez les médecins
c'est que les hommes et les femmes
aspirent à avoir une conciliation de vie
professionnelle et de vie familiale et
donc ce qu'on appelle à tort
féminisation c'est juste comment on
arrive à avoir une vie qui permet
d'avoir ces deux dimensions là d'assumer
je pense aussi que le taux de
féminisation est un indicateur utile qui
corrélé aux conditions de travail
puisqu'en effet une profession qui se
féminise de manière majeure et de
manière
rapide montre que c'est une dégradation
des conditions de travail j'entendais
qu'aujourd'hui elle allait s'ouvrir le
CNR pour l'éducation et qu'on se posait
les questions de recrutement en crèche
et dans la petite enfance peut-être il
faudrait regarder un sujet sur la
dégradation des conditions de travail
qui même quand les femmes ne vont plus
sont particulièrement compliquées et
puis comme Muriel sale j'avais la même
conclusion c'est-à-dire la prise en
compte des spécificités des femmes aux
spécificités de genre et voir à la lutte
l'idée vulnérabilité au sens large
finalement moi je je regrette de ne
parler qu'à des femmes à chaque fois que
je dois parler de santé des femmes je
pense qu'on parlait de santé du handicap
nous n'avons pas que des personnes en
situation de cap qui sont présentes et
heureusement la santé des femmes n'est
pas une question de femme du coup je
vous je remercie la délégation d'avoir
la gente masculine présente parce que je
pense que c'est un sujet de société et
de vivre ensemble voilà
c'est ça mais ça veut dire que c'est
peut-être ça le premier problème
si je suis d'accord merci beaucoup
madame depot pour cette présentation
extrêmement complète et oui nous sommes
très heureux de partager à la fois la
victoire mais du contenu aussi sur le
travail des femmes puisque j'imagine que
le sujet du travail des femmes pour la
délégation
marocaine qui est avec nous ce matin est
un sujet aussi donc je vais tout de
suite passer la parole à notre dernière
intervenante qui en visio avec nous Elsa
boulet et ensuite bien entendu les
rapporteurs et les membres de la vous
poseront des questions mesdames puisque
notre première intervenante a dû nous
quitter pour un autre rendez-vous donc
juste précision nous avons des hommes et
des femmes qui siègent dans cette
délégation mais elles sont assez peu
représentées ce matin puisque quatre
porteurs se sont finalement proposés
pour être travaillé sur ce sujet de la
santé des femmes au travail et nous
n'avons pas eu forcément de candidatures
hommes donc ça s'explique peut-être par
votre remarque finale madame depot donc
Madame Boula je vous ai on vous écoute
depuis le Sénat merci à vous
le micro
votre micro madame
on vous entend toujours difficilement
vous voit bouger les lèvres
alors si ça devait mettre trop de temps
peut-être que on passera directement en
question dès que je vous entends
j'arrête de remplir le l'espace
donc je ne vous entends toujours pas
n'ayez pas peur ça va bien se passer
c'est les inconvénients du télétravail
qui sont qui étaient citées tout à
l'heure pour les femmes et qui celui-ci
n'en faisait pas encore partie mais la
technique parfois ne nous aide pas
forcément
qu'on va passer des questions aux
collègues et dès que vous arrivez à vous
connecter madame boulet depuis Nantes on
vous reprend bien entendu donc est-ce
que suite à l'intervention madame depot
on a des collègues rapporteurs qui
souhaitent intervenir et réagir aux
propos
non vous n'êtes toujours pas connecté et
donc notre rapporteur Annick Jacquemet à
une réaction est d'ailleurs peut-être
que si il y a d'autres réactions dans la
salle on aura le temps de les prendre
avant que vous soyez connecté madame
boulet
oui moi je suis déjà merci merci pour
vos propos pour votre présentation
claire j'ai été très surprise quand vous
parliez du discours dissuasif parce que
c'est un discours que moi j'ai entendu
quand j'étais jeune et c'est vrai que ma
maman me disait quand j'ai voulu faire
mes études à me dire mais pourquoi tu
t'embêtes de toute façon tu vas te
marier tu auras des enfants et puis
voilà donc moi j'ai connu finalement un
peu cette lutte pour arriver à faire ce
que je voulais faire et je suis surprise
que 40 ans après on soit toujours encore
dans ce même schéma là et là vraiment je
pensais quand même que les choses
avaient évolué et en tout cas que les
jeunes filles que les jeunes femmes
se prenaient un peu plus en main et puis
était un petit peu plus
indépendante de ce genre de
de schéma tout fait et la deuxième chose
quand vous parliez des femmes et études
supérieures je pense parce que pour la
petite histoire je suis vétérinaire et
c'est vrai que dans les écoles véto
c'est aussi on a beaucoup plus de femmes
mais dans 80% quand moi j'ai commencé en
été une poignée enfin et il y a aussi je
pense
qu'un stage là les les filles sont plus
travailleuses que les que les garçons et
que certains types d'études elles
réussissent mieux tout simplement parce
qu'elles sont plus bosseurs et qu'un
stage là les garçons ils pensent parfois
plus à faire la fête qu'à être derrière
les bouquins et je pense que c'est aussi
quelque chose
qui compte
on va prendre toutes les questions et
donc Marie Pierre Richer et Raymonde
pourcemonge
c'est pareil oui par rapport au critères
de pénibilité qui ont été quand même
très bien mis en avant au moment où on a
allongé de la retraite de 60 à 62 ans
les fameux dit critères avec les quatre
qui ont été abandonnés moi à l'époque je
dirais une activité de service de soins
à domicile et effectivement je me suis
fait la remarque que alors on était dans
le prendre soin là que en fait c'était
non seulement des critères je dirais qui
s'appliquait plus aux hommes mais
surtout de l'industrie c'était des
critères de du secteur secondaire quoi
en quelque sorte et pas du tout du
secteur tertiaire enfin et secteur
tertiaire où il y a des femmes donc ça
ça reboucle et effectivement si on prend
par exemple les crèches
moi j'ai une fille qui est éducatrice de
jeunes enfants vous prenez des enfants
toute la journée pour les pour les
changer etc un critère qui va faire la
répéter parce que vous dites
effectivement les charges 25 kg etc ça
c'était très visible en EHPAD c'est très
visible y compris dans mon activité à
domicile que j'avais avec le portage des
personnes âgées ou des personnes mais
même comment mettre dans un critère
pénibilité le fait qu'on va prendre 30
fois dans la journée voire plus un
enfant dans les bras etc donc
et cette question là enfin doit monter
puisque à chaque fois je dirais on nous
fait le coup de on va s'occuper de la
pénibilité afin de pouvoir rallonger le
temps de travail moi je peux vous dire
que quand la retraite est passée de
enfin l'âge de la retraite de 60 à 62
ans j'avais dit dans 10 ans la courbe
des inaptitudes dans mon association
coupera la branche de départ à la
retraite j'aurais pu de départ à la
retraite pour partir en inaptitude et
c'est ce qui s'est passé donc c'est pas
très difficile un petit peu un documenté
et donc mais comment puisque on nous met
en avant ces critères pénibilité dans le
secteur tertiaire et ses métiers du
point de soin avec aussi la
confrontation à des publics de plus en
plus au bord de la crise de nerf et qui
est dans les voilà on peut avancer ou
alors il y aura une difficulté
méthodologique quoi prendre en compte ça
d'un rapporteur Marie-Pierre Richer on
vous laissera répondre après et Laurence
Cohen et ensuite on vous passera la
parole je crois madame Boulay puisque
vous avez réussi à vous connecter
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
pour votre pour votre exposé vous il est
noté vous avez noté que les femmes
subissent plus force plus fortement la
transformation sociétale des familles
c'est ce que j'ai noté quelle est ta
votre avis l'impact générationnel est-ce
que
puisqu'on pourrait considérer que
aujourd'hui les il y a une génération
qui est plus au fait quand même et qui
est notamment chez les hommes qui
devrait s'investir aussi un peu plus
dans la vie entre guillemets domestique
donc de ce point de vue là il y a-t-il
pour vous une évolution une stagnation
une régression et quel est l'impact
environnemental entre
les femmes qui évoluent en milieu rural
et les femmes qui évoluent en milieu
urbain merci
et donc pour finir ce tout petit tour de
table orange Cohen vous répondez et
Madame boulet oui merci beaucoup pour
pour votre propos introductif qui est
qui a qui nous a donné beaucoup beaucoup
d'éléments ce que j'ai trouvé
particulièrement
disons intéressants c'est quand vous
faites le parallèle entre le fait que
dès qu'une une profession et très
féminisée je vais le dire comme ça
finalement les déclasser et je trouve
que ça c'est important parce que on est
là sur le fait que
on part vraiment de la place des femmes
dans la société donc les femmes sont
naturellement je mets plein de
guillemets patiente dans
l'accompagnement dans le soin etc et
donc comme c'est naturel elles n'ont pas
besoin de formation particulière et donc
elles ne sont pas reconnues et donc les
salaires voilà suivent cette
ce stéréotype de de société donc ça ça
me paraît un élément quand même
important parce que ça explique beaucoup
de choses et du coup
on voit aussi que tout ce qui a été qui
a été fait par finalement le patronat
d'une manière générale sur le temps
partiel il est parti d'une d'une
aspiration on va dire de la société
c'est-à-dire dire bah oui je vais
travailler moins alors les femmes avec
cette idée de dire je vais travailler
moins comme ça je vais concilier pour
mes enfants donc c'était une vraie
aspiration et en même temps le fait de
de de
d'instituer ces temps partiels sont
venus temps partiel imposées et ils ont
c'était comme un laboratoire
d'expérimentation en quelque sorte qui
est après a été élargi à l'ensemble du
salariat et ça a donc entraîné plus de
précarité des salaires moins importants
et donc au bout du bout une retraite
aussi moins importante et des conditions
de travail extrêmement pénibles donc
voilà c'est c'est sur ces facteurs là
aussi que j'aimerais peut-être vous vous
entendre je vous remercie par avance
alors je vais essayer de faire vite pour
laisser du temps à Madame à Madame
boulet sur le fait de est-ce que on est
on a coupé un peu avec le schéma
traditionnel on va dire de pouvoir faire
de pouvoir travailler j'aurais tendance
à dire oui et non oui dans le sens où
pour les femmes c'est évident que il va
falloir travailler et malgré tout non
sur la partie stéréotype c'est-à-dire
que elles veulent quand même elles
intègrent le fait de trouver un travail
qui est compatible avec une vie
familiale et avec une vie de couple et
c'est dans ce sens là où on a gagné un
peu mais pas complètement c'est-à-dire
qu'on aura gagné quand
elle l'intégreront au moment où c'est
opportun c'est-à-dire que au moment même
de faire des études elles se pose déjà
cette question là du coup elles accèdent
même pas aux études donc ne savent même
pas qu'elles pourraient tout à fait
conseiller vie professionnelle et vie et
vie familiale mais parce qu'elle ne se
l'autorise même pas au départ donc en
fait elle s'auto censure donc c'est
comment on va travailler l'estime de soi
sur ces dimensions là pour que dès le
plus jeune âge on se dit bah oui je peux
les faire et peut-être faire des mois de
témoigner les femmes en disant bah moi
j'ai une vie épanouie de professionnels
et j'arrive à me conseiller aussi un
modèle qui m'est propre et à chacun son
modèle en fait donc oui oui mais non
pareil sur la partie et tu te supérieur
oui ça a été démontré qu'en effet les
jeunes femmes sont des bonnes élèves et
donc c'est par souci parce qu'elles sont
meilleures qu'elles accèdent au concours
et qu'elles sont placées c'est pour ça
que je parlais de celle qui change en
termes de taux de féminisation c'est à
dire que j'ai pris l'exemple médical
parce que les médecins avant étaient
majoritairement masculins et ils sont en
train de basculer à passer
majoritairement féminin ce dont je n'ai
pas d'avis sur le sujet si ce n'est que
quand on voit les études c'est que ce
n'est pas par hasard que les hommes sont
en train de quitter la profession
médicale c'est-à-dire qu'ils études
montrent que c'est parce qu'en effet
aujourd'hui un homme va avoir tendance
vu qu'il est moins dans cette notion du
je vais prendre soin je vais faire du
Caire etc de manière inhérente il est
beaucoup plus rationnel dans son choix
et dit quels sont les bénéfices risques
du métier auquel je postule et que
aujourd'hui les risques
les conditions de travail qu'on lui
propose en tant que futur médecin sont
bien moins bonnes que les conditions de
travail qu'on va lui proposer dans
d'autres secteurs et donc va avoir
tendance à aller chercher dans les
autres secteurs dès le début de la
formation donc c'est dans ce sens là où
je suis évidemment d'accord avec vous
c'est ça a été aussi complètement
démontré que il y a il y a un effet et
intelligent qui existe et
heureusement mais que c'est la partie
changement de de pourcentage de
féminisation de d'une profession sur la
bilité sur la reconnaissance oui je
regrette aussi que les risques
psychosociaux soient peu pris en compte
et je vous dirais bien que c'est parce
qu'il faudrait faire appel aux équipes
de recherche aux chercheurs et un peu
moins ces stéréotypes et que des travaux
il en existe il en existe de plus en
plus c'est qu'il y a des laboratoires
dont je ne fais pas partie mais dans les
travaux sont passionnants et qui aborde
ses dimensions là parce que mais ça veut
dire aussi accepter un coût économique
majeur parce que les risques
psychosociaux dont je vous ai parlé
quand on parle après en termes
d'assiette de personnes concernées et
donc de coup induits je pense qu'il y a
peut-être aussi logique économique à
part reconnaître certains risques
psychosociaux pas parce qu'ils touchent
particulièrement les femmes mais parce
qu'ils sont particulièrement nombreux en
terme de effectivement mais qui reste un
sujet majeur
sur le partage des tâches et l'évolution
je pense qu'on a parfois un peu biaisé
par nos propres microcosme que oui c'est
me démontrer que par exemple dans
certaines franges à citer un peu plus
enfin moins fragiles en attente à avoir
un partage si ce n'est que le partage au
moment de l'arrivée du premier enfant a
tendance à rebasculer sur des schémas un
peu traditionnels c'est-à-dire que y
compris parmi les couples dans lesquels
avant l'arrivée d'un premier enfant il y
a une répartition qui est relativement
équilibrée au moment de l'arrivée du
premier enfant il y a une bascule qui se
fait et il y a une responsabilisation
qui se fait par sur les femmes il y a le
congé maternité qui induit ça qui fait
qu'à un moment la femme on l'a on lui
donne cette ce contrôle social aussi en
lui reconnaît ce rôle social là le congé
parental est souvent pris par les femmes
et puis sur le temps partiel
mais ça évolue quand même mais on avait
gagné je crois 6 minutes au dernier au
dernier statistiques de répartition de
tâches et sur le temps partiel subit je
vous dirai juste parce que je pense
qu'il faut que je m'arrête que le temps
partiel subi qui est aussi que quand
c'est les femmes qui l'occupent elles
occupent un temps plein en étant payé à
temps partiel et que la problématique
allait elle est criante de ce niveau là
et qu'elles se font une double peine
et bien je crois merci pour ces réponses
madame de Pau et je pense qu'on va
pouvoir vous donner la parole madame
boulet vous avez réussi à vous connecter
et on vous a un petit peu entendu déjà
donc priori je voilà on est on est
connecté à votre visio on vous écoute
merci à vous merci madame la Présidente
est-ce que vous m'entendez bien parfait
donc je vais partager mon écran
normalement vous devriez voir mon
diaporama qui s'affiche
écoutez on peut démarrer puisque il
s'affiche et on pouvait l'avoir aussi
sur table donc tout va bien vous pouvez
démarrer madame
bien tout d'abord merci beaucoup à la
délégation au droit des femmes pour
cette invitation moi je vais faire un
focus sur la question de la grossesse au
travail mais vous verrez qu'on va
retrouver un certain nombre d'éléments
que mes collègues ont déjà abordés là ce
que je vais vous présenter c'est issue
d'un travail de recherche que j'ai mené
auprès de femmes enceintes résident en
région parisienne et occupant des postes
divers des niveaux hiérarchiques assez
divers et c'est aussi des résultats
fondés sur une exploitation de l'enquête
nationale périnatale de 2016 qui est
réalisée par l'adresse et par
l'hémisphère
quelques éléments de contexte tout
d'abord que vous connaissez sans doute
au moins en partie mes collègues m'ont
rappelé les femmes non seulement ont
toujours travaillé mais aujourd'hui sont
majoritairement en emploi tout au long
de leur vie c'est aussi le cas pendant
la grossesse puisque 70% des femmes
étaient en emploi pendant leur grossesse
même si on sait par ailleurs que le taux
d'activité des femmes diminue avec le
nombre d'enfants c'est un autre sujet
des mesures spécifiques existent dans le
droit du travail français dans les
conventions collectives à destination
des travailleuses enceintes notamment
les congés prêts et postnataux le droit
de s'absenter de son travail pour se
rendre au consultations médicales
obligatoires ou encore la protection
contre le licenciement pendant le congé
maternité des aménagements du poste de
travail etc
la France elle se caractérise aussi par
un parcours de soins standardisé un
suivi de grossesse qui est financé par
l'assurance maladie et qui est très
largement suivi par les femmes même si
on repère des inégalités
socio-économiques assez importantes en
termes de suivi médical
alors malgré ce contexte qui semble a
priori favorable on note plusieurs si
vous voulez faire passer votre diaporama
en même temps comme ça
c'est pas grave
j'en suis à la troisième diaporama
la troisième diapo si
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est bon de votre côté
écoutez non on voit que la première
image mais c'est pas grave continuez on
vous suit et on l'a sur table d'accord
très bien
donc malgré ce contexte qui semble a
priori favorable au travailleuses
ensemble on note plusieurs plusieurs
difficultés premier point on remarque un
taux d'emploi qui est plus faible au
moment de la naissance que pendant la
grossesse 65% au moment de la naissance
versus 70% au cours de la grossesse ce
qui signifie qu'une partie des femmes
perdent ou quitte leur emploi en cours
de grossesse et ça j'y reviendrai dans
la fin de ma présentation
un second constat qui complète le
premier c'est un taux de chômage qui est
beaucoup plus élevé au moment de la
naissance que pour les femmes de la
classe d'âge de 24 à 49 ans au moment de
la naissance 18% des femmes sont au
chômage contre 9% des femmes
âgées de 24 à 49 ans
autre constat qui interroge c'est la
fréquence des discriminations déclarées
en raison de la grossesse ou de la
maternité c'est là un constat qui a été
dressé par le Défenseur des droits dans
son rapport de 2017 sur les
discriminations au travail le Défenseur
des droits note que la grossesse ou
maternité arrive au troisième rang des
motifs de discrimination dans l'emploi
les plus fréquemment déclarés par les
femmes et les femmes qui ont été
enceintes ou mère d'un enfant en bas âge
ont été deux fois plus la cible de
discrimination au travail que les autres
femmes
enfin dernier constat c'est celui
d'arrêt de travail de longue durée qui
sont nombreux pendant la grossesse je
renvoie là aux travaux épidémiologiques
de vigoureux et Sorel qui note que plus
d'un quart des femmes enceintes cessent
leur activité rémunérée avant la fin du
second trimestre de grossesse donc bien
avant le congé dit de maternité
c'est là un constat qui n'est pas
nouveau puisque on note la même chose
depuis les années 70 et depuis les
premières enquêtes périnatales ces
différents éléments donc ils amènent à
s'interroger sur les obstacles auxquels
sont confrontés les travailleuses
enceintes et les conséquences de ces
obstacles à la fois sur le travail des
femmes et sur la santé des femmes
alors premier élément pour commencer à
répondre à cette question je vous ai mis
quelques Verbatim pour illustrer mes
propos sur sur les diaporamas premier
élément que mon étude a mis en lumière
c'est la persistance d'une
stigmatisation de la grossesse en milieu
professionnel cette stigmatisation elle
prend des formes très diverses qui
peuvent être subtiles ou au contraire
très frontal et dans certains cas très
graves elle peut prendre la forme de
propos des obligeant ou d'attitude
hostiles de la part des collègues
directs ou encore de la hiérarchie il
est important de souligner ici que c'est
ces attitudes hostiles étaient pas
systématique dans les témoignages des
femmes que j'ai rencontrées mais ils
sont suffisamment fréquents et
suffisamment déstabilisant pour que
toutes les femmes même celles qui ne
sont pas confrontés directement les
anticipes et les craignent
dit autrement toutes les salariés même
quand elles ne sont pas confrontées à
des attitudes hostiles ont intériorisé
la suspicion et l'hostilité potentielle
de leur milieu professionnel vis-à-vis
de leur grossesse
et certaines femmes que j'ai rencontrées
qui occupaient des emplois de cadres
faisaient même état dans un véritable
sentiment de trahison à l'encontre de
leurs collègues ou de leur hiérarchie du
fait de leur grossesse
alors cette stigmatisation réelle ou
anticipée intériorisés elle a des
conséquences puisque les salariés vont
chercher à minimiser la visibilité de
leur grossesse sur le travail et
minimiser les conséquences de leur
grossesse ça va par exemple les amener à
renoncer à certains droits qui sont
pourtant prévus par le code du travail
par les accords de branche et
conventions collectives notamment ce qui
va concerner l'aménagement du temps de
travail
elles vont par exemple ne pas demander
la réduction d'une heure par jour de
leur temps de travail qui devrait
pourtant leur être accordée ou encore
renoncer à l'autorisation de s'absenter
pour se rendre à leur consultation
médicale
dans la mesure où les salariés enceintes
sont très rarement remplacées pendant
leur congé maternité en tout cas parmi
les femmes que j'ai rencontrées c'était
vraiment beaucoup plus d'exception que
la règle les femmes enceintes vont aussi
anticiper que leur charge de travail
qu'elles ne pourront plus effectuer
pendant leurs congés va être redistribué
sur leurs collègues ce qui peut les
amener à redoubler d'efforts en amont de
leur congé maternité pour clôturer des
dossiers terminer un certain nombre de
choses avec là encore des conséquences
sur leur santé en termes de stress et
d'épuisement à titre d'exemple une cadre
que j'ai rencontrée racontée qu'elle
avait augmenté son temps de travail et
qu'elle ne prenait plus de pause pendant
sa grossesse en anticipation de son
départ en congé maternité avec bien sûr
des conséquences sur sa santé
autre point autre élément important j'ai
pu constater au fil de ma recherche que
les aménagements du poste de travail
était très rare voire bien souvent
malheureusement inexistant ça tient à
plusieurs choses premièrement ça tient à
la méconnaissance de leurs droits par
les salariés qui étaient souvent assez
peu au courant de ce qu'elle pouvait
demander ce qui était possible ou non
mes connaissances qui étaient rarement
compensées par l'intervention de du
supérieur hiérarchique ou du service des
ressources humaines
pour informer les salariés
ce que j'ai pu constater c'est que les
aménagements du poste de travail étaient
rarement organisés par la hiérarchie et
on avait plus souvent à faire à des
arrangements informels entre collègues
donc les salariés ensemble pouvaient
compter sur la solidarité sur l'entraide
de leurs collègues directs pour pour se
ménager et pour pour éviter certains
risques professionnels
vous l'avez sur le diaporama je vous
donne l'exemple d'une chercheuse en
biologie qui est amenée à manipuler des
produits terratogènes pendant ces
expériences elle n'a pas elle n'a pas
obtenu d'aménagement de son poste de
travail pour éviter ces manipulations
mais par contre elle s'est arrangée avec
ses collègues pour limiter son
exposition à ses produits chimiques
un autre point qui me semble important
de souligner quand j'interrogeais ces
salariés sur la pénibilité les risques
liés à leur travail ce qui ressortait le
plus souvent c'est en réalité une
pénibilité et des risques généraux qui
concernent l'ensemble des salariés et
pas que spécifiquement les femmes
enceintes ça pourrait être le stress le
port de charge les risques de
contamination biologique ou chimiques et
donc là on retrouve un élément que mes
collègues ont déjà abordés qui est de
souligner que quand on s'intéresse à la
santé des femmes au travail en réalité
ça permet de parler de santé au travail
de manière plus générale et chercher à
améliorer les conditions de travail la
santé des femmes et bien ça a des
conséquences positives sur tout le monde
alors les effets de ces différents
phénomènes sur la santé des salariés
enceintes sont de plusieurs ordres une
dégradation de l'état de santé avec de
la fatigue des malaises dans certains
cas l'aggravation de pathologies
préexistantes dans d'autres situations
encore des menaces d'accouchement
prématurées etc
il faut prendre en compte que toutes les
femmes ne sont pas à égalité mais que
les inégalités sociaux économiques sont
là à prendre en compte
il faut prendre en compte que les
inégalités socio-économiques sont
imbriquées au genre quand on parle de
santé au travail ce que j'ai pu
constater par exemple c'est que les
cadres et les femmes qui occupaient des
postes de cadres et des professions
intermédiaires avec plus de marge de
manœuvre pour négocier leur poste de
travail leurs horaires et donc préserver
leur santé alors que les employés en
situation voilà de subordination
hiérarchique avait beaucoup moins de
marge de manœuvre
ce que relève vigoureux et Sorel dans
leur étude c'est que les arrêts de
travail dit précoce donc au cours du
second trimestre de grossesse sont plus
fréquents parmi les femmes peu
qualifiées ou en situation de précarité
même en l'absence de progrès de
problèmes de santé préexistants donc ce
que signifie ce que ça signifie c'est
qu'en réalité bien souvent l'arrêt
maladie
joue le rôle de palliatifs à des
conditions de travail inadaptées qui
mettent en danger la santé des femmes et
la bonne issue de la grossesse
il y a aussi des conséquences sur
l'emploi des femmes je vous ai mis
quelques chiffres sur le diaporama j'ai
pu montrer à partir de l'enquête
nationale périnatale de 2016 qu'une
femme sur dix perdait ou quitter son
emploi en cours de grossesse alors
malheureusement les données sont pas
suffisamment précises donc on ne sait
pas quelle est la raison de cette sortie
de l'emploi est-ce que c'est une
démission est-ce que c'est un
licenciement est-ce que c'est la fin
d'un CDD etc en tout cas ce qu'on sait
c'est que cette sortie de l'emploi
concerne une femme enceinte sur 10 qui
quand même assez notable et que pour ces
femmes là dans plus de 9 dans plus de
90% des cas elle se déclare au chômage
en recherche d'emploi c'est à dire
qu'elle considère que leur sortie
d'emploi et soit subi soit temporaire
c'est pas des femmes qui quittent leur
emploi pour devenir femme au foyer ça
c'est une chose dont on est à peu près
sûr
et ces éléments quantitatifs ils
viennent corroborer les témoignages que
j'ai pu recueillir de la part de
salariés ensemble qui faisait état pour
certaines d'une rupture de leur contrat
de travail après avoir annoncé leur
grossesse à leur employeur pour d'autres
de la difficulté de la difficulté voir
de l'impossibilité de retrouver un
emploi si elle se trouvait au chômage
pendant la grossesse
et là encore il faut prendre en compte
les inégalités socio-économiques puisque
c'est conséquences sur l'emploi des
femmes sont très différenciées selon les
caractéristiques des travailleuses les
sorties de l'emploi concernent 20% des
femmes qui occupent des emplois ouvriers
ou de services mais seulement 5% des
cadres et des indépendances par exemple
elle concerne 16% des femmes à temps
partiel contre 9% des femmes à temps
plein je me permets de d'insister un
petit peu sur ce résultat puisque on
aurait pu penser que le temps partiel
était finalement une configuration
plutôt bénéfique et protectrice plus de
temps pour concilier avec la vie
personnelle moins de fatigue au liées au
travail rémunéré en fait ce qu'on voit
c'est que le temps partiel est plutôt un
facteur de fragilisation et ça ça tient
à la structure des emplois en France
mais mes collègues l'ont déjà rappelé
les temps partiels sont très souvent
enfin se retrouvent très souvent dans
les secteurs féminisés qui sont peu
qualifiés qui sont précaires peu
rémunérés avec des conditions de travail
difficiles donc c'est tout ça en fait
qui est compris dans le temps partiel
et enfin les femmes nées à l'étranger
sont beaucoup plus souvent concernés par
par ces sorties d'emplois que les femmes
nées en France
et par ailleurs on sait que les
indicateurs de santé périnatale sont
bien moins bons pour les femmes et à
l'étranger que pour les femmes nées en
France
et tous ces éléments là en fait
relève le mettre en lumière
l'imbrication entre travail et santé en
matière de santé périnatale on sait que
ne pas avoir d'emploi et corréler à un
état de santé moins bon à la fois pour
la mère et pour l'enfant
et donc c'est donc la grossesse en fait
exacerbe des inégalités préexistantes en
termes d'emploi et santé et en quelque
sorte joue le rôle de miroir grossissant
si vous voulez de ces différents
phénomènes
alors pour finir quelques pistes de
réflexion que je vous soumets première
piste c'est il me semble la nécessité
d'une meilleure information des
travailleuses qui passent sans doute en
partie par le rôle des employeurs des
services des ressources humaines
autre piste un éventuel recours à la
médecine du travail encore faut-il que
cette médecine du travail soit
correctement formé et outillés c'est ce
que souligner Muriel salle tout à
l'heure
ces éléments pointent aussi la nécessité
d'une application réelle des mesures
destinées aux travailleuses enceintes
puisque on voit que dans la réalité il y
a quand même un hiatus important entre
ce qui est prévu par le droit et ce qui
se fait réellement
j'espère que je vous ai aussi convaincu
que s'intéresser aux conditions de
travail à la santé des salariés
enceintes en réalité ça pose des
questions plus larges sur l'organisation
du travail et les risques professionnels
généraux qui ne sont pas spécifiques aux
femmes enceintes et enfin on a parlé de
modèles familiaux et de l'implication
des hommes dans le travail domestique et
parental ça soulève il me semble la
question pourquoi pas d'un congé second
par an qui pourrait commencer avant la
naissance afin que les femmes enceintes
et un relais réel à la Maison de la part
de leur conjoint je vous remercie pour
votre attention et je me tiens à votre
disposition
et bien merci beaucoup on vous a très
bien entendu et les problèmes de micro
étaient loin derrière nous donc suite à
cette présentation extrêmement
exhaustive je vais laisser les
rapporteurs s'ils le souhaitent réagir
ou vous poser des questions et tout
d'abord notre collègue rapporteur
Laurence Rossignol bonjour
merci pour votre travail et votre
présentation et c'est sûrement je crois
que c'est vraiment important de
d'introduire la question de la grossesse
dans notre rapport sur la santé des
femmes au travail ça me permet de vous
partager avec vous une préoccupation que
que j'ai depuis un moment c'est que on a
toujours dit pour préserver l'égalité
professionnelle et l'insertion des
femmes dans le travail la grossesse
n'est pas une maladie c'est une
assertion c'est un postulat la grossesse
n'est pas une maladie mais en fait à
force d'avoir dire que la grossesse
n'est pas une maladie on
déni et on dissimule aussi le fait que
la grossesse est un extraordinaire
bouleversement physiologique avec des
impacts importants sur la condition
physique des femmes et la condition
psychologique et je me demande ce qu'il
faudrait pas qu'on rompe avec cette
cette ce postulat que la grossesse n'est
pas une maladie pour arriver à trouver
le mot qui permettrait de faire
comprendre que les femmes pas serrer les
dents pendant toute la grossesse
lorsqu'elle travaille voilà ça fait un
moment que je me posais cette question
là parce que je pense qu'on est un piège
cette histoire de grossesse qui est pas
une maladie et dire que c'en est une
c'est un piège aussi donc comment on
sort du comment on sort du piège ça
c'est ma première remarque à 2e remarque
c'est plutôt pour mes collègues et notre
rapport c'est qu'il faudra pas qu'on
oublie la question des femmes
professionnelles
dans la question de la grossesse vous
vous avez traité la question du samedi
des femmes salariées plus précisément
mais voilà toute la question des
professions libérales qui ne sont pas
remplacés la couverture le problème de
remplacement des congés de maternité de
leur propre assistante qui est aussi il
y a aussi un sujet de droit de droit
aussi qu'amène des assistantes à rester
longtemps pour pas mettre la patronne en
difficulté enfin parce que c'est des
équipes de travail intensif une dentiste
une assistante dentaire c'est une équipe
de travail donc elles prennent sur
elle-même donc il faudra qu'on pense
bien à traiter de cet aspect là la
troisième chose que je voulais évoquer
aussi avec vous c'est sur la
l'augmentation la durée des congés
l'important taux de congé pendant la
grossesse alors on a le travail mais
peut-être parce que je suis élu d'un
département qu'on pourrait qui est le
sud des Hauts de France l'Oise mais qui
est quand même un peu le nord de
l'Île-de-France dans son mode de vie je
dis ça pour madame qui était dans les
Hauts-de-France et dans lequel de
nombreuses femmes ont des temps de
transport très très long et le travail
n'est pas dissociable dans beaucoup
d'endroits du transport pour aller au
travail et de l'impact du transport sur
la grossesse et je dis ça par
observation purement pyrique c'est que
beaucoup de femmes sont arrêtées pendant
leur grossesse pas tant parce qu'il faut
qu'elles peuvent pas tant pour
l'exposition au risque du travail que
pour l'exposition aux risques du trajet
domicile-travail voilà j'ajoute c'est
plus large ça et puis enfin dernière
remarque et purement
esthétique presque sur la
sur-représentation des femmes à
l'étranger dans le retrait du travail je
pense qu'il y a quand même plusieurs
facteurs il y a pas qu'il y a la
causalité pas toujours dans le travail
c'est aussi des femmes qui peuvent être
dans des familles avec des modèles plus
traditionnels ou le travail c'est un
moment de vie qui n'est pas compatible
avec les enfants on travaille jusqu'à ce
qu'on est des enfants et on arrête de
travailler où on des enfants mais je
sais pas si vos études permettent de
d'identifier quels sont les je crois que
non c'était pas assez poussé
d'identifier quel est quel est le
ressort sur l'arrêt du travail et
effectivement comment on peut permettre
à ces femmes elles aussi que de de
changer de schéma familial parce que
c'est le rôle de la République de
permettre à toutes les femmes qui vivent
en France de bénéficier de ce que la
République apporte comme promesse
d'égalité
merci beaucoup chers collègues je vais
prendre toutes les questions si vous le
permettez donc Marie-Pierre Richer
rapporteur il y aura également Raymonde
pourcement je ne sais pas si Annick
souhaitera
Annick Jacques maire rapporteur si elle
souhaitera intervenir également donc si
vous pouvez prendre en note les
différentes questions madame Boulay et
vous pourrez répondre à l'issue de ce
tour de table merci merci madame la
Présidente merci Madame pour votre
exposée mon intervention va rejoindre
les propos de Laurence Rossignol parce
qu'il y a ce week-end il y avait un
article dans la presse
concernant le constat que notamment dans
les cabinets d'avocats les futurs maires
de famille sont contraintes de ne pas
s'arrêter de travailler au delà des
remplacements elles évoquent notamment
la somme qu'il aurait proposé par la
Sécurité Sociale et l'ordre des avocats
de 2820 euros par mois et cette somme
qui ne permet pas de payer des
collaborateurs et des stagiaires donc on
a aussi ça rejoint ce que tu disais et
ça pose un vrai problème et c'est j'ai
lu cet article comme un vrai cri de
détresse de cette profession je suppose
qu'il y en a d'autres mais c'était
c'était un exemple qui que je voulais
porter peut-être pas votre connaissance
vous le savez mais voilà ça fait partie
des points que nous aurons à travailler
merci
beaucoup chers donc Raymonde pense à
Monge oui merci même Annick moi par
rapport à les conséquences sur l'emploi
des femmes là les femmes en emploi au
moment de la grossesse ayant occupé un
emploi
et qui ne sont plus au moment de la
naissance moi j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre les
9,3% donc du coup qui aurait quitté leur
emploi ou qu'on aurait forcé à quitter
leur emploi je sais pas y compris des
licenciements économiques
et qui
s'inscrivent donc au chômage et
recherche un emploi puisqu'elles sont
protégées pendant leur grossesse parce
que aussi il y a un enfin des arrêts
enfin il y a les congés maternité qui
vont faire qui vont relayer un petit peu
dès notre troisième trimestre donc c'est
ces 9 3 là je me demande vraiment
comment on peut avoir non pas 10% qui ne
sont plus au moment de la grossesse
de la naissance je veux dire ça ça
m'étonne pas particulièrement mais que
la quasi majorité en fait se retrouve en
recherche d'emploi alors qu'elles
étaient protégées et qu'elles allaient
bénéficier quand même des congés
maternité là j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre ça à part si elles ont été
licenciées économiques
alors on finit le tour de table avec la
rapporteur Annick jacquemay et après ça
sera à vous de répondre madame boulet
je voudrais simplement rajouter comme ma
collègue Laurence Rossignol parler des
professions libérales je crois que
puisque j'en suis une je pense quand on
est professionnel on comment je vais
dire ça on a tellement de l'habitude de
gérer plein de choses en même temps on a
une approche peut-être un peu différente
on n'est pas salarié donc on se prend en
main et la grossesse finalement ça fait
partie de ce qu'on fait moi j'ai eu
trois enfants quatre ans j'ai toujours
continué à travailler enfin voilà je
pense et puis toutes mes amies
professionnelles
bah voilà on a nos enfants même tant que
notre boulot on se posait moins les
questions puisqu'on a la limite pas le
choix mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on les a
mal vécu ces grossesses au contraire
mais je pense que l'approche est
peut-être un peu différente parce que
parce que c'était comme ça maintenant
les choses ont quand même beaucoup
évolué pour les professions libérales
pas énormément parce qu'au début quand
les jeunes professeurs libérales tu fais
ta clientèle tu fais tout en même temps
et puis voilà quoi mais après je pense
que ça dépend aussi des caractères c'est
que quand on arrive à mener ça c'est
qu'on a aussi le caractère pour donc
pour voilà moi je mets un peu
si simplement réagir par rapport aux
professionnels merci beaucoup chers
collègues pour nous faire partager cette
expérience l'idée bien entendu c'est de
d'avoir cette approche
historique mais également de voir quel
est l'impact de ces conditions de
travail sur sur la santé des femmes et
forcément ces parcours difficiles auront
un impact donc Madame boulet vous avez
donc quatre sénatrices qui vous ont
interpellé suite à vos propos et votre
exposé qui était déjà très complet je
vous laisse y répondre et ensuite je
laisserai madame Depot qui souhaitait
aussi réagir par rapport à votre
intervention je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour les questions et
c'est un commentaire je vais répondre
dans les ordres commencés par la
question sur
on va dire plus technique sur
qu'est-ce qui se passe pour que ces
femmes se retrouvent en recherche
d'emploi alors comme je le disais
malheureusement les données de l'Enquête
nationale périnatale se sont pas
extrêmement précises donc on ne sait pas
si l'emploi occupé pendant la grossesse
était un CDI qui du coup a été rompu à
l'initiative de qui on ne sait pas si
c'était un emploi en intérim et que donc
la personne a terminé son sa mission on
ne sait pas si c'est un CDD qui s'est
terminé pendant la grossesse si la
personne n'a pas repris ensuite un autre
CDD donc voilà malheureusement c'est des
informations qui restent assez accélères
ensuite concernant la protection pour
que licenciement la protection contre le
licenciement n'est valable légalement
que pour ma période du congé maternité
ce qui veut pas dire que les femmes ne
pourront pas contester un licenciement
qui qui intervient avant mais le droit
interdit de licenciement pendant la
période des congés prénataux et POS
et par ailleurs alors là c'est pas du
tout spécifique aux salariés enceintes
mais entre le droit prévoit et les
pratiques réels il y a toujours un
décalage et j'ai pu constater dans mon
étude auprès de femmes que j'ai
rencontrées que j'ai interviewé que les
licenciements existaient alors soit une
rupture du contrat qui est assez
ouvertement abusive où on renvoie une
jeune femme en alternance en lui disant
qu'elle a rien à faire ici parce qu'elle
est enceinte et que voilà elle
elle n'a rien à faire dans son
alternance autre situation que j'ai
rencontré une jeune femme qui
travaillait comme esthéticienne et que
sa patronne a renvoyé juste avant la fin
de sa période d'essai sans dire très
explicitement que c'était en lien avec
sa grossesse mais en tout cas c'est bien
comme ça que l'interpréter cette salarié
donc voilà la situation des des femmes
salariés enceintes peut être quand même
assez flou et ou assez à distance de ce
qui est prévu officiellement en tout cas
par le lien
concernant les professions libérales et
indépendantes je vous remercie pour ces
remarques c'est effectivement un point
qui est très important que j'ai moins
spécifiquement étudié pour ma part là
aussi on a un problème de données
puisque on n'a pas de d'études de
portance spécifiquement sur les
professions libérales et les
indépendantes ce que l'enquête nationale
périnatale permet quand même de voir
c'est que les indépendantes ont
globalement des conditions d'emplois
plutôt meilleur mais des conditions de
santé plutôt moins bonnes et là
effectivement ça renvoie à ce que vous
disiez de difficultés de se faire
remplacer la nécessité de travailler le
plus tard possible
et les difficultés d'indemnisation
également
difficultés qui concerne non seulement
les professions libérales mais qui
peuvent concerner d'autres types de
profession j'ai rencontré par exemple
des femmes qui étaient intermittentes du
spectacle et pour lesquels se posent
exactement le même genre de questions
d'indemnisation de congés
en ce qui concerne les transports et la
pénibilité des transports c'est
évidemment un enjeu majeur et pour ma
part l'étude que j'ai réalisé était en
région parisienne donc là la question
des transports et évidemment centrale
et pour ma part je suis tout à fait
convaincue de la nécessité d'intégrer
les le temps et les conditions de
transport à la réflexion sur les
conditions de travail puisque si on
prend ces transports et si on y passe
autant de temps c'est bien pour aller
travailler donc je considère qu'il
s'agit un peu du même du même paquet si
vous voulez et là encore et bien se joue
toutes sortes d'inégalités est-ce qu'on
invite très loin en banlieue ou en zone
rurale périurbaine ou est-ce que on a
les moyens d'habiter en centre-ville
est-ce qu'on occupe un emploi qui permet
de télétravailler ou non est-ce qu'on
arrive à négocier avec son employeur une
télétravail ou non et ainsi de
et dernière précision pour les femmes
nées à l'étranger alors là encore on est
contraint par des données qui sont assez
voilà qui sont pas extrêmement précises
ce qui est certain à ce qui est
documenté par d'autres travaux c'est
qu'à l'heure actuelle les femmes qui
imigrent en France sont plus diplômés
que la moyenne des femmes nées en France
mais par contre elles sont confrontées à
des discriminations très fortes sur le
marché du travail ce qui peut
éventuellement être combiné avec des
modèles familiaux mais qui en tout cas
amènent à un taux d'emploi qui est plus
faible et un déclassement de ces femmes
combien même elles auraient été
diplômées voire très diplômés dans leur
pays d'origine
de prendre en compte différents facteurs
et différents organismes excusez moi je
peux poser une question parce que c'est
la première fois que j'entends ce que
vous dites c'est que les femmes qui
émigrent en France sont plus diplômés
que la moyenne des femmes françaises
c'est une peut-être parce que je suis
ignorante mais c'est même pas peut-être
c'est je suis ignorante c'est c'est quoi
la référence de de cette enquête parce
que comme on a un débat immigration dans
quelques semaines je peux vous dire que
c'est pas tombé dans l'oreille d'une
sourde
et sur les femmes immigrées je pense
notamment aux travaux de Pauline Vallot
qui enseignant de chercheuse à
l'Université de Dijon d'accord
je vais chercher moi aussi je voudrais
juste dire en tac au tac la femme est
protégée quand elle est enceinte dès le
troisième mois dès qu'elle demande
d'ailleurs souvent son heure de
transport et pas simplement pendant le
congé prépostnatal dès que l'employeur
a la déclaration de la elle est protégée
par le droit du travail heureusement
parce que s'il fallait attendre
ça c'est une précision de droit du
travail
est-ce que vous avez fini
les les alors effectivement il y a des
bouleversements la grossesse en
elle-même induit des choses notamment
induit une fatigue peu induire d'autres
formes de symptômes là encore il
convient de prendre en compte de façon
un peu plus précise quelle est
l'activité effectivement réalisée par la
travailleuse quelles sont ses conditions
de travail puisque à état de on va dire
à état physique équivalent ça va pas te
donner du tout les mêmes choses si on
bénéficie d'une certaine autonomie dans
son travail si on est assise à un bureau
ou si au contraire on est soumise à des
cadences à des ordres qu'on ne peut pas
contester à des déplacements fréquents
donc le
la question n'est peut-être pas tant de
reconnaître la grossesse comme une
maladie ou la traiter comme une maladie
mais plus largement d'intégrer l'état de
santé mais de tous les salariés en
réalité et pas uniquement des femmes
enceintes de prendre en compte l'état de
santé réel au travail pour obtenir une
certaine souplesse et une certaine
reconnaissance du fait que les
travailleuses et travailleurs ne sont
pas des machines mais bien des personnes
en chair et en os qui peuvent arriver le
matin au travail dans différents états
physiques et psychiques
et bien écoutez je vous remercie je
laisse madame
de Pau intervenir suite à votre
présentation madame boulet c'était juste
une remarque sur des questions qui vous
a été posée mais sur la partie vu que
moi je travaille pour les médecins
libéraux la question de la
reconnaissance des grossesses pour les
femmes médecins libérales se posent à
chaque fois y compris en termes
d'attractivité c'est-à-dire que quand on
veut favoriser l'installation
des médecins libéraux et des médecins
femmes libéraux
s'est posé la question de la couverture
et de la période de la grossesse et que
les lignes ont commencé à bouger et que
il y a une reconnaissance maintenant et
une prise en charge de l'assurance maïs
de cette situation là pour cette
profession libérale là donc les choses
bougent peut-être pas complètement mais
elle commence quand même à bouger et
par contre maladie ou pas mal a dit
c'est la même chose pour la ménopause
est-ce qu'on est malade quand on est
ménopausées est-ce qu'on est malade
quand on est grossesse non en fait c'est
en effet des états physiologiques qui se
modifient et que c'est ça pose la
question du comment les organisation
s'adapte à des changements de vie tout
court on en parlait en termes de prise
en compte de la douleur de prise en
compte de la pénibilité de prise en
compte de tout en fait vous pourrez vous
pouvez aussi vivre un deuil vous pouvez
avoir à ce moment une détresse
psychologique qu'il est importante
prendre en compte donc c'est finalement
comment on prend en compte bah une
trajectoire de vie personnelle qui va
venir se percuter à une organisation du
travail qui qui ne devient plus
compatible temporairement ou de manière
plus durable
et bien écoutez je vous remercie
sincèrement pour ce temps d'échange à la
fois les trois intervenantes madame
Boulay qui vient d'intervenir madame
depot et également Muriel sales qui qui
était avec nous tout à l'heure je
voudrais vraiment vous remercier pour
cette audition qui a permis d'apporter
un éclairage à la fois sur l'histoire du
travail des femmes sur la sociologie on
a vu des sujets pointés notamment avec
les rapporteurs qui qui vous ont
interrogé sur différentes thématiques
qui ont en réaction à vos à vos
présentations l'articulation évidemment
du temps personnel et du temps de
travail les troubles
musculo-squelettiques qui restent à un
sujet majeur avec la pénibilité le temps
partiel des sujets d'ailleurs qui font
écho chers collègues à la retraite aussi
finalement puisque c'est carrières de
temps hachées de temps partiel ont un
impact considérable sur sur la condition
dans les conditions dans lesquelles les
femmes prennent leur retraite je
voudrais dire sur
aussi des conditions de travail très
dégradées sur la grossesse des salariés
nous avons voté dans la loi l'index de
l'égalité il y a quelques années donc
avec cinq critères forcément à la
lecture des critères et à la lecture
aussi du périmètre pour lequel
s'applique cette index de l'égalité nous
devrons pour faire progresser les
conditions de travail des femmes dans
dans les entreprises et aussi dans dans
la fonction publique d'ailleurs évoluer
sur cette index de l'égalité parce que
on le voit la grossesse et vous l'avez
dit Madame Boulay et
un moment une situation où la carrière
des femmes peut basculer ou la carrière
des femmes peut être freinée ou la
carrière des femmes peut rencontrer de
grosses difficultés donc nous nous
devons évidemment de faire progresser
cette index de l'égalité qui devra
peut-être prendre en compte d'autres
critères puisque nous avons mis le congé
notamment
que nous avions sur table et puis je
vous souhaite vous mesdames une bonne
une bonne journée avant de nous quitter
nous avons une tâche supplémentaire à
faire c'est que il y a une deux sujets
cette année à l'ordre du jour de la
délégation c'est évidemment la santé des
femmes au travail mais également un
sujet avec la délégation aux outre-mer
et notre collègue Stéphane Artano qu'il
a préside et donc victoire Chassin a été
nommée rapporteur pour cette mission et
donc je vous propose puisque Stéphane
Artano président de la délégation
outre-mer donc je vous proposerai la la
candidature d'Elsa
la candidature en deux minutes c'est
fait la candidature d'Elsa Shaq et et la
mienne et sur ce nous aurons terminé
est-ce que c'est validé par mes
collègues oui merci pour moi et Elsa qui
est parmi nous ce matin je vais conclure
en salon la délégation marocaine qui
nous a accompagné ce matin et qui a
permis de gagner un petit peu en parité
inversée donc merci à vous Mesdames et
Messieurs députés je vous avais pu
profiter d'une audition de travail avec
quatre apporteurs très engagés sur ce
sujet et on le voit des pistes
législatives forcément
arriveront à l'issue de ces travaux
parce que le travail forcément peut être
aussi encadré et je pense que ce travail
va être extrêmement riche avec nos
quatre collègues rapporteurs issus de
groupes différents et c'est toute la
qualité du travail de la délégation de
d'arriver à mettre ensemble des
sensibilités différentes et pourtant
d'avoir des conclusions souvent très
souvent partagées merci à vous pour
votre présence ce matin et bonne journée
à tous